Dr R is back with another Advanced
JavaScript course he'll teach you how to
build a virtual environment entirely
from the ground up get ready to use
basic HTML CSS and JavaScript to craft a
world you can use in all kinds of
projects he'll show you how to fill the
world with self-driving cars but you can
fill it with anything you
[Music]
like
hi and welcome to phase two of the
self-driving car course a virtual
world this is actually a standalone so
you don't need to have watched phase one
to follow along we'll start building
this world from scratch using some basic
HTML CSS and a lot of JavaScript and
whether you'll fill it with self-driving
cars or something else is completely up
to you the focus will be on generating
the world itself and I'll only integrate
the self-driving car code at the end I
made this course to prepare for phase
three understanding AI where we'll focus
on neural networks and other AI
techniques I hope that by the end of
face three you'll understand why neural
networks work why hidden layers are
needed and things like that but for that
we need this fancy world to generate
complex scenarios the one we had earlier
is too simple to teach you all that so
if neural networks is what you're
waiting for be patient and enjoy phase
two meanwhile you learn a lot of things
in this one as well a set of skills I
really benefited from during my PhD and
my time at Microsoft and I'm sure
they'll be useful to you as well in your
career we first learn about graphs and
I'll show you how to implement the
spatial graph from scratch I'll also
show you how to make an editor for it as
well it will have a dynamic viewport so
we can pan and zoom to edit graphs of
virtually any size when building this
editor I'll explain the mathematics and
logic behind good user interfaces in
modern pieces of software and we
Implement something similar
ourselves then we use geometry to
generate the road borders around the
graph I'll teach you about polygons and
some useful operations using them we'll
apply the same techniques in a slightly
different way to generate the buildings
and the trees as well we spent two
lessons on these because I want to show
you how to implement this 3D look as
well they're not really 3D models just a
little bit of math that gives that
illusion then we Implement a way to add
markings to the road this will make
phase three even more interesting
because we'll need to teach the car to
respect all kind of traffic roles as
well now we'll focus on making this
world editor a pleasure to use
minimizing the number of clicks and
maximizing the amount of autogenerated
content but I'll also make videos on how
to load real world data from open street
map so the car can drive in your city as
well this is yansu the card just passed
by kelia University of applied science
that's the Vila campus where I'm
currently filming and it started off at
tiar the other campus and now it's
heading toward City Center where I've
marked some it companies on the map
looks like the car is heading towards
Arbon out which is on the other side of
town I'll add a link to this demo in the
description check it out it's a good way
to learn about yansu if you plan to come
study with us you'll find many useful
links there as
well oh and I'll also make a video for
creating this mini map it really helps
when the world is big and the mini map
was probably the most requested feature
I got in phase one I've tried answering
to all requests when making this but
there's still a few I'm leaving for
phase three they fit better
there now to be clear this project is
complex especially because we're going
to code everything ourselves and not use
libraries it won't be easy to wrap our
minds around at all but I divided it
into components lesson that I believe
are easy to understand on their own I
consider this course to be at an
intermediate level but I do encourage
beginners to give it a shot as well to
get an idea of what a more complex
project looks like I explain everything
the best I can and if you have
difficulties just ask in the comments or
on my Discord the prerequisites are high
school math and if you have trouble with
that this playlist will have you covered
you also need to know some JavaScript if
you completed phase one you'll have no
problems here but if you need to brush
up on it I explained some tricky
JavaScript syntax in these sketches so
check them out if needed I hope you're
excited and thanks for being patient
this long can't believe it took me over
a year to make this but I wanted to do
it justice since you liked phase one so
much now let's begin I'm going to code
everything using visual studio code and
we'll begin somewhere in an empty folder
on your computer
and let's create our first file here
it's going to be
index
HTML and we begin with basic HTML we
write the doc type here and the HTML
page
structure in the head I'm going to add a
title and the title of this will be the
world
editor this will make it appear in the
browser Tab and let's make it also
visible by typing it inside of the body
in an H1
tag like this now most of our
functionality is going to be built on
top of an HTML canvas element so let's
add canvas element with ID my
canvas onto the page as well
now let's open this in our
browser I'm going to be using Google
Chrome and remember to open the
developer tools as well it's really
important to know if you make any
mistakes the errors will pop up here now
you can see here the title of the page
is correct and the H1 tag is here but
the canvas is not really visible it is
there if you press this button right
here you can find it on the page but
it's transparent and we can see it so
let's add some styles to this page I'm
going to go here below the
title and Link a CSS file like this
called Styles
CSS we're going to create this file
here Styles
CSS and for the bot
I'm going to give it a black background
color and I'm going to align everything
to Center like this the H1 I'm going to
give it a white color so that we can
read it on the black background and set
its font to harriel I think it looks
better and finally the canvas I'm going
to give it a back color that we can see
on this black background and I'm just
going to use this shade of green that I
like let's save this and refresh and it
now looks like this I'm going to make
the canvas bigger and we're going to use
JavaScript for
that in index
HTML we'll write JavaScript code here at
the end of the body we begin with script
tag and I'm going to set my canvas width
to 600 and my canvas
height also to
600 because it fits my screen well
pretty much but you can choose other
values if you want now we're going to be
drawing on this canvas and for that
we're going to need to access the 2D
drawing context of this canvas like
cell and we will draw a graph let's
pretend that we have a way to define a
graph like
so and that the graph has a way to draw
itself on a given context so we're going
to need to implement these
functionalities the graph itself and the
draw method and we'll do that in a
separate Javascript file
I'm going to include it here we're going
to place JavaScript files in a folder
called JS but this is going to be a
pretty big project so we need to think
about code structure early
on and I'm going to place the graph
itself in a subfolder called math and
then graph JS like
so so let's create the Js folder
first and inside of this JS folder we're
going to create math another folder and
inside of math we create our Javascript
file graph. JS graphs are data
structures made from a set of nodes also
called vertices and a set of edges or
links that represent relationships
between the nodes like in a social
network a graph can store which users
are friends these relationships are
bidirectional here but in other
applications like here on YouTube I may
be subscribed to you but you may not be
subscribed to me there is very much to
say about graphs like we already use
graphs in Phase One when implementing
the neural network there the links had
weights so we were dealing with a
weighted graph and there was a link
between every input and every output so
we used the Matrix to represent those
relationships in memory but now we're
going to implement a new type of graph
called a geometric or spatial graph
where nodes are not just abstract things
they will represent Road intersections
or places where the road geometry
changes like this you can see there are
not so many links here really so a
matrix would be mostly empty and not the
right choice in this case when
implementing a spatial graph the proper
way would be to separate the node
metadata the points from the connections
themselves but I think it makes things
too complicated and since this whole
project revolves around geometry I will
simply say these are the points and they
will be connected by segments with one
point at each end so a bit
unconventional here but I think it
simplifies things in our case now let's
code one of these graphs in JavaScript
it's going to be a simple
class and each Constructor is going to
have two parameters we build a graph
using
points and
segments I initialize them to empty
arrays so that you can create an empty
graph as
well now let's store these parameters
as
attributes like so and in Implement our
draw method that takes the canvas
context as a
parameter and I'm just going to Loop
through all of the segments that we
have and tell each of those segments to
draw themselves on the canvas context we
don't have these segment objects yet but
they will be there and they will have
the same kind of structure as the graph
has it's important to be consistent with
these things and then I'm going to do
the same thing for the
points like
so and uh I draw the points after the
segments because I don't want the
segment lines to be on top of the points
it doesn't look
good now let's Implement these segment
and point objects in index HTML I'm
going to copy this line
and I'm going to place these in a folder
called Primitives points and segments
are primitive objects so let's write
here
Primitives point
and
Primitives segment like this and inside
of this JavaScript folder the main one
here not inside of math
I'm going to create a new folder called
Primitives so it's next to the math
folder here and in it we create a new
file Point JS it's also going to be a
very
simple class Constructor takes in X and
Y as parameters where we want the point
to be and we set these paramet
values as class attributes like so so
that the object knows where it is pretty
much and then in the draw method on the
given context I'm also going to pass two
more parameters to style these points a
little bit the first one is going to be
a size maybe 18 pixels and a color I'm
just going to use
black we're going to draw the points as
circles and the circles need a radius
I'm going to just calculate that as half
of whatever this size is and we begin a
path set the fill style to this color
that we have in the parameter list and
use the arc method of the drawing
context and draw this at this X and this
y we pass the radius next and the last
two parameters specify that we want a
full circle so starting at
0° and ending at
360° but we have to write this using
radians that's just how the function
works so
360° is 2 pi
radians now we fill and we're done with
this point for now let's do the same
thing with the segment so create a new
file called segment
JS our segment
class The Constructor will have points
this time P1 and
P2 let's save these as attributes of the
class and Implement our draw
method given a context and again I'm
going to pass two parameters here as
well the width the line withd how thick
we want the segment to be I'm just going
to give it a default value of two and a
color again I will set it to Black like
so and we begin a
path we set the line width to the given
width and we set the stroke style this
time to the given color we move to the
first
point
p1x P1 Y and now we're going to copy
this
line and line
to P2 X P2
Y and then we
stroke and we're done with these core
functionalities the only thing left to
do is test so make sure all your files
are saved go back to index HTML and
let's pass some actual points to this
graph I'm going to go
here above where we defined the graph
and
say P1 is a new
point at
200 200
pixels let's copy this few more
times and have here P2 P3 and P4 maybe
P2 is going to be at 500 200
then 400 400 and 100 300 and let's pass
these as an array to our graph here as
well
this will be the points parameter of the
graph and the segments will be the
second parameter but we can actually
test now already so save the file
refresh the page and there's our graph
it has the four different points this is
the
200200 this is the 500 200 uh keep in
mind that 0 0 is this top left corner so
5 100 200 like
so let's add segments as well I'm going
to go here and
say S1 is a new
segment between P1 and P2 and let's copy
this two more times maybe S2 and S3
between let's just link P1 for now P1
with P3 and P1 with P4 and pass these as
the second attribute
here save and refresh and we can see now
the segments as well let's connect these
to as
well so I'm going to copy this as
S4 between P2 and P3 and passing s for
here like
so good now this is a static structure
we can't really edit it in any way and
the next thing we'll do is add some
functionality to add points remove
points add segments remove segments and
so on we'll do that in a very basic Way
by adding here buttons that just add
some of those elements on the screen I
want to teach it like this because it's
how interfaces were made 30 years ago
and then we're going to make it modern I
want you to see how things have changed
since
then so let's go up here and below our
canvas element I'm going to define a div
with an idea of
controls and this is going to contain
some buttons that we can press to do
operations with our graph the first
first
button on click it will call a function
called add random
Point let's call this button add Point
like this give it the
label and let's implement this add
random Point function next I'm going to
just make it here on top of this script
these functions will go away at some
point we just need them to develop the
core functionality so I'm not going to
worry about the code structure too much
and add
random
point it's going to tell the
graph to add a
point the graph object will have this
functionality so let's pass here as the
point a new point and give it random
coordinates so X is going to be random
and I'm going to scale this by the width
of the canvas so that the value is not
between zero and one what this gives but
between 0 and 600
pixels and the height in the same
way now to see this point after it was
added we have to refresh the canvas we
do that by clearing the whole canvas
starting get 0 0 top left corner and
with
height bottom right corner and then we
tell the graph to draw itself again so
graph draw on the context so let's
implement this ad Point function real
quick we are going to go to graph
JS and here below the Constructor we say
add point a given
point and we just take the points
attribute of the class and
push the given point like so now let's
refresh and when we press this button
you can see a new point was added there
you can try pressing it multiple times
and it's going to work pretty much
always unless we run out of memory but
uh that's not going to happen anytime
soon now there is one situation that I
want to take care of I don't want to
have two points at the same location it
makes no sense points are identified by
X and Y and if you have two of them with
the same X and Y then that's the same
point so let's see how we do that
we're going to need a function that
checks if the graph already contains a
point
right and I'm going to write it like so
using the array find method which finds
inside of these
points a
point that
equals the given
point like so what happens here is that
the find Loops through all of the points
here and let's call them p and then
Returns the one that equals point and if
it doesn't find that point then it's
going to return nothing so something and
nothing will also correspond to true and
false in Boolean logic and we're going
to use this as such it's just how
JavaScript
works so equals here here we need to
implement as a method to the point class
we need to check if p is equal to the
point somehow so inside of the point
class I'm going to
implement
equals
point and return if this x is equal to
point x and this Y is equal to point Y
like so
this will only be true if point and this
are the same and now we could go here
and check to see if the graph contains
the point before adding it or we could
add the new method to the graph that
tries to add a
point and then maybe we monitor here the
success did it succeed to add a point or
not let's log this in the
console right here so we can go inside
of graph
JS here and try add
point is going to check if this point is
not part of the graph at the
moment then we
add the
point and notice here how I'm reusing
the method we defined earlier then we
also return
true it was a success
otherwise we return false like this
let's save a refresh and when we press
this add
Point same thing as before happens
pretty much but we always get here this
true and that's because it's really
unlikely to randomly generate another
point on top of an existing one but to
test we should force that to happen
somehow so I'm going to go here in index
HTML copy this entire function
here paste it here in the console and
instead of having random I'm going to
write 0.5
and
0.5 this means that I'm going to
overwrite this function so that it
generates the points always in the
middle of the screen so if we press
multiple times on that button the same
point will come again and again to
overwrite we have to press enter
now and let's press this point again
once and this is the point in the middle
of the screen and when we try adding
another one we get our false as well so
it wasn't a
success and the number of points in our
graph
points
18 doesn't
change now we have a way to add points
to our graph let's add segments as
well we're going going to go here and
copy this button and call the other one
add
segment and the function will be add
random
segment and we Define that function
here at random
segment this will work a little bit
differently it first gets the points
that we want to connect and then creates
the segment let's get these points again
at
random by using floor of random
times the number of
points floor makes sure that we have an
integer value and let's copy this for
another index two
different points and then tell the graph
to add the
segment a new
segment between the
points at index one and
points at the index
to like this now to see any changes
after we press this button we also need
this thing right here clearing and
redrawing the graph
so let's save this and go to graph JS to
implement this add segment
method we go
here below the points section and let's
Implement add
segment let's call it seg and it's going
to take the segments of the graph and
push this new one at the end let's save
this refresh and now when we press add
segment it added a segment here and now
I pressed again and nothing
happened let's try
again
nothing nothing
nothing what's wrong can you figure out
what the problem
is pause the video now and try to figure
out the answer for you yourself or just
listen to me carry
on the issue is that here where we are
adding these
segments sometimes index one and index
two could be the same so we create a
segment from one point to itself we
could check here and
say success is
false and then if index one is different
than index
two success is true let's also add the
segment only in that case because a
segment from one point and to itself
doesn't really make sense and let's log
this success here as
well refresh and when we press add
segment we get a true and we see the
segment when it appears but
sometimes we get the false when we try
to link the same point to
itself and if we press more
times
oh we got the true now but I didn't see
any
change what happened try to figure out
what happened pause the video and now
I'm going to tell you the
answer
so turns out it's possible that you add
the same segment multiple times as well
like maybe now this segment was just
added again let's actually see here in
the console the
segments and the last segment
between 200 200 and 100 300 I think
that's this one here
yeah and you can see they're exactly the
same let's try adding few more
segments even though they are going to
be copies of
themselves and now we see here 18
segments but we can really only count 1
2 3 4 5 six so it doesn't make sense to
have more than six segments here we
wouldn't be able to see them and we
wouldn't be able to tell that there are
duplicates
there this last one actually is the same
that we had previously but in Reverse P1
is P2 and vice versa we're going to need
to handle that case as well so let's go
back here and convert this into a
Triad segment as well and move that to
the success and have the same kind of
structure as here pretty much let's go
to the graph and implement this
method
try add
segment and it's going to be very
similar to the try add point but we
first check if this contains the segment
and if it doesn't then and we add
segment and return
true and here we return
false like so this contain segment is
going to
be here and what we
do is again use defined method on the
segments this
time I'm going to Loop through them
using this s and find the one that
equals the given segment like so we're
going to need to implement equals
functionality for the segment as well so
here
equals is going to
be
return P1
equals seg do
P1 and
P2
equals seg do
P2 but we also want the opposite check
if the points are flipped so we're going
to do
or P1 equals seg P2 and P2 equal seg
P1 now if we we refresh and add a few
segments we can see there false
appearing many
times eventually one of them will
work okay so now we have all six of them
here and when we go in the console and
type graph segments they are indeed six
so it works but before we move on this
line of code is quite complicated here
checking so many things and it's always
good to try to simplify two segments are
the same if they include the same
points so we could make a helper method
here called
include
point and return this P1
equals point or this P2 equals point so
now we have a way to check if the
segment includes a point and two
segments are equal
if this
includes P1 and this
includes P2 it makes sense and if you
save and
refresh it still works but it's nicer to
read in this way and you'll see that
later we'll need this includes for other
reasons as well now this part here where
we check to see if the indices are
different we could incorporate it part
of the Triad segment so try to see if
the points are equal and if they are it
won't add the segment so we could
actually have success here defined as so
and we don't need to use let here we can
use const again so try add segment now
is going to not only check if it doesn't
contain the segment but
also
if P1 is not
equal
B2 let's save refresh and try adding
segments
again and we still have six
here great now let's go to index HTML
and have a way to remove these segments
also I'm going to copy this and say here
remove a segment at random and
remove segment
like this and the function for removing
is going to be like
this I'm going to first check to see if
there are any segments so
if graph segments
length is zero you can also have a
methods added to the graph that check if
it has segments or Returns the point
count if if you want to do a really
really proper job but this is Javascript
then I don't bother too
much so here I'm going to
log no segments just as a warning that
no bother trying to remove something
there's nothing to
remove and return and otherwise we are
here where we get a random
index from the segments this
time and remove
segment the one at that
index like so we also need to copy this
code
here otherwise we won't see the change
after it
happens and now let's implement this
remove
segment I'm going to go here and say
segment
splice so splice removes elements at the
given index here we get the index of
this segment and I want to remove just
one element the segment itself now you
can add many other methods here maybe
removing the segment by the index we
already had the index here to begin with
or try to remove a segment similar as
those other ones but they won't be
needed in our project and I'm not going
to over engineer
this refresh and remove
segment okay okay okay
okay all good and if we try one more
time no segments written in the console
great let's remove the points as well
for that I'm going to add another button
here remove
random
Point
remove
point and let's copy this remove random
segment like this and have here remove
random
point if
graph points are empty no
points index is going to come from the
points this
time
remove
point
graph points and let's implement the
function remove point in the graph file
let's copy this remove segment and put
it here in the points section and rename
it to
remove point the given point and it's
going to look inside of the points array
and
supplies the points index
of point would have been faster to just
rewrite this but I wanted to show you
how similar these functions are now
let's save this refresh and when we
remove a
point we can see it's
gone but I'm removing all the points and
and now we also get that message there
but the segments are still there and
that makes no sense how can you have
segments between points if there are
points so let's make it so that when we
remove a point it also removes all the
segments that contain this
point so the New Logic will be
here let's first get some
segments with point the given
point and then for each segment of this
small
list we remove the
segment like so using the method that we
have defined
earlier so we need to implement this get
segments with point and I'm going to do
that here in the segments
section get segments with
point we we start off with an empty
array and now look through all the
segments of this
graph
if the segment includes this
point then we add it to this array and
at the end here we just return
the array of segments that contain this
point simple enough let's refresh and
remove point and you can see that the
segments connected to it are also
gone let's try adding some
points adding some random
segments question for you given a number
of points how many segments can there be
between them like in this
case we have 17 points how many segments
can there be here let me know in the
comments and now we can also try
removing some
segments removing some
points good everything seems to work but
one more useful button to have here
would be to clear everything to remove
everything I'm going to implement the
method for that here it's really easy
let's say this will be
dispose of the
graph and I'm just going to set the
points and the segments to empty setting
the length attribute like this doesn't
generate new objects for them so it
reuses the same array object and in
index
HTML let's copy this and say remove
remove all remove all and the remove all
function call graph
dispose and we need to copy this again
if we want to see the update
refresh and it works now you could build
an interface like this maybe when adding
point it wouldn't just be a random point
but have there some inputs for the X and
the Y adding the segment maybe it can
have a drop down for the first point and
the second Point removing again a drop
down with all the segments and all the
points and that interface would work but
it would have so many clicks and so much
use of the keyboard that nobody would
use it
nowadays I will teach you how to make a
modern interface
so we won't need these buttons
here let's remove them actually I will
keep the control section here because we
might use it later but no need for these
functions at all all that was important
was to have here all these useful
methods inside of the graph
Class A good user interface is one that
minimizes the number of clicks and
keyboard input I'll teach you how to
build a graph editor that does that now
in other courses I've considered mobile
as well but in this series I'll focus on
the mouse because I think it's the best
tool when creating graphs it has two
easy to press buttons we can use for
adding dragging and removing
points we'll implement the editor step
by step adding new features when needed
and polishing existing ones until we're
happy with the final logic at least I'll
be happy with it but if you're not I
hope you'll get the skills to edit
things in or out just the way you want
we will Define our graph editor here
after we have the graph and we
initialize it like
so new graph
editor passing the canvas it's going to
need that for event listeners and the
graph and it's going to also be doing
all the drawing on the canvas so
actually we don't need this call anymore
it's going to be handled by the graph
editor and the editor is going to be
very interactive it's going to change
all the time depending on our Mouse
moves and the simple way to implement
this is using an animation Loop so a
function that we call here and start to
animate and it's going to be really
simple all it does
is it
clears the canvas because it's going to
redraw again and again so clearing
starting at 0 0 and all the way to the
canvas width and canvas height and then
we'll have our graph
editor display itself it knows where the
canvas is because it has it here as a
parameter and finally we call Quest
animation
frame and pass this animate call again
and again and again it's going to be
kind of a recursive call where the
browser will try to recall this function
60 times per
second so we're ready to implement this
graph editor and we'll do that in a new
file I'm just going to Define it here in
the main JavaScript folder so it's going
to be called graph
editor and injs create a new file graph
editor
JS the class is a simple
class and the
Constructor will get the canvas and the
graph as parameters now let's set these
values as
attributes so that the editor doesn't
forget
them and let's have a reference to the
canvas drawing context as well defined
here as a class attribute so that we
have easy access to it like
so and the display
method for now let's just have it draw
the graph
on this
context save the file refresh the page
and it looks pretty much the same as
before but now if you go to the console
and you type for
example
p1.x is equal to
400 and press enter you're going to see
immediately that point jump to a new
position because it is rendering again
and again and again all the time you
just don't see it so we are ready to
start adding event listeners for the
mouse action I'm going to create a
private function private method for this
here so it starts with the hashtag and
then add event
listeners and this method is going to be
here below the
Constructor the first event listener we
add to our
canvas
is going to be for Mouse
down and we get the information from
this event and write the arrow function
so this Arrow function let's close it
here and now implement the body the
first thing we'll do is get the mouse
location from the mouse down event from
The Click so Mouse is going to be a new
point and the information is inside of
this
EVT do offset X and EVT offset y are the
XY location of the click now with this
point we can just tell the graph to add
the point and the code should work so
let's refresh and click
somewhere and there you go points added
anywhere we want them so it's an
improvement over the randomness we had
previously now one thing that we'll
really need in this editor is the
ability to select a point and let's
Implement that so that the last point
that we add is also
selected we'll have a more complex Logic
for the selection later but now it's
just like that to test so I'm passing
here this selected is equal to the mouse
and this selected will be attribute of
the class initially null it can be null
if we don't select anything and then in
the display
here let's draw it separately in a
different way so if we do have a
selected point I'm going to tell this
point to draw
itself under the context but this is
just going to draw it on top of itself
already it's already there from this
graph draw so I want to specify a little
bit different properties for this
selected point and let's give it an
outline we don't have this functionality
yet so let's save this go to our Point
primitive here and in the draw method
add an outline here now the more
parameters you add here the more
difficult is going to be to remember
their order so I like to group these as
an object like
this and now you could pass them in any
order you want you just need to
specify these properties the name of
these properties here like what we just
did so if you want to pass this without
these options we write here equal to an
empty object and then you can just
called Draw as we did before in the
graph now this outline I'm just going to
go here below and if we do have an
outline We Begin another
path set the line width of two for
example and let's give it a stroke style
of
yellow and draw a new arc at X and Y but
our radius will be a little bit smaller
I don't want it to be exactly the
outline I want it to be kind of inward I
like the look of that so let's say
radius time
0.6 and again 0 2 pi for drawing a
complete circle and again if you want
this selected point to look different
just make it different it's your code
now now let's save this
refresh and now when we click somewhere
we're also going to have that point that
we just added selected and this is how
it looks like and the next thing we do
in our logic is when we click on a point
that is already existing I don't want to
create a new point on it or close to it
so I actually want to select that point
and at the moment this doesn't happen it
just creates a new point on top of it
pretty much so let's see how we do that
we first have to figure out what point
are we hovering
over so going back to our graph editor
in this mouse down event listener after
we have our Mouse
location we get the hovered Point by
looking at the nearest Point so we're
going to need the function get nearest
point from the mouse from all the graph
points like this and then if this
hovered Point
exists we are going to select it like
so and now I'm going to return so the
code doesn't go here anymore for adding
a new point and selecting it it just
select let's define hover also in the
Constructor here same as
selected hovert initially null and what
we need to do is implement this get
nearest Point somewhere and what I like
to do is create a new file and Link it
here in index HTML it's going to be also
part of math and we will call this new
file
utils JS this will have utility
functions mostly math functions that
will help us during our
project so in math create a new file
called utils
JS and the function for getting the
nearest
point to a location from a set of points
point is going to be a basic minimum
search so we look for the minimum
distance from our location to all the
points and select the point with the
minimum
distance we do that by initializing this
minimum distance to a very large value
like this and the nearest Point let's
just have it null in the beginning and
then we Loop through all the points
in the array like this and calculate the
distance
between that point and the location that
we have here as a
parameter if this distance was found to
be less than our supposed minimum
distance then minimum distance becomes
distance and we record the point with
this minimum distance as well in this
nearest attribute then we go here at the
bottom and just return
nearest and what we still need to do is
implement this distance function between
two points and this is really easy we've
done it countless times I have a special
video about it it uses the Pythagorean
theorem and we just return the Hot
between the difference on X and the
refence on y between these two points
let's
refresh and now when we
click you see it selects a point it
always selects the nearest point when we
click somewhere but we can click
anywhere really and maybe we would like
to have a limit so that we are close to
that point to actually select it because
at the moment we can't add new points
anymore we're always is just
selecting so what we'll do is when we
look for the nearest point we'll check
also if the point is under a threshold
so this third parameter threshold let's
have it 10 I like to have it just a
little bit bigger than the points so
that you can click almost there and it's
still going to work and then here our if
is going to check and the distance is
less than the threshold then it does
everything let's save refresh and now
when we click here it adds new points
but when we are close to something it
selects that point and you can still get
nearby points if you are outside of that
threshold but if you're close enough you
actually select it play around with this
and let me know what you think what
should the proper threshold
be now our get nearest Point function
here should have this threshold as an
optional value really
because the name implies it's going to
find the nearest no matter what so the
threshold here I'm going to Define it to
be this very large value that we can use
and then in graph
editor when we get the nearest point I'm
going to pass here 10 like so now
refresh the page and the code will work
as before pretty much what would be
really nice is to know if I'm going to
click here will this add a new point or
will it select the other one are we
inside of the threshold or not and we
should know this before doing it
otherwise we get surprised by what
happens so visualizing the intent is
important I think and that's that's what
we're going to do
next we are going to need to define a
new event listener for Mouse move this
time so Mouse
move and on every Mouse move we are just
going to take this hovered Point like
so and here in the display we will
visualize this hovered Point as well in
another
way let's copy these lines
and say if
hovered draw the hovered one as well and
this one let's emphasize it with the F
this time so F set to true and inside of
the point we pass now this fill as
well by default it's
false and at the end here I'm going to
check if we do want this point to have a
special kind of fill We Begin The Path
and we draw a new
arc again at The X and Y and the radius
I'm going to have it smaller this
time full
circle and let's remember also a fill
style I'm going to set it to yellow and
instead of stroke I'm going to call fill
let's save this and refresh and now when
you move the mouse over the point you're
going to see the highlighted point so
you know if you see that that once you
click it's going to select it and if
you're close but you don't see that and
you're going to click it's going to
create the new point so the interface is
not surprising anymore it's much more
useful for the
user I don't like this point I think
it's too close to that one so I would
like to remove it somehow and I'm going
to implement removing of points by right
clicking on the
points we go to our graph
editor in our Mouse down here and
actually we don't need this hovered
anymore because it's already happening
here on Mouse move so we could remove it
entirely and nothing will change
everything will still
work and to implement the right click
we're going to go here at the top and
check if we press the right click or not
that information is also part of the
event and we do if event button is
two this means right click and I write
here a comment because I always forget
which is which then if if this
hovered I'm going to say graph remove
point this hovered like so and the logic
from here is if we have
pressed
zero which is left
click now you maybe know why I'm
confused about these numbers sometimes
let's save
refresh and now when we right
click something happened you actually
don't see this but I have this menu
appearing on the
canvas and let's get rid of that so to
get rid of this rightclick menu I'm
going to add here another event
listener for context
menu
and the function I'm going to pass is
going to call prevent default this is
just going to prevent that menu from
coming up now let's test again clicking
on the same
point it removed the
segments connected to that point but not
the point oh also the point but for some
reason the point is still
visible until I move my mouse away from
it and that's because when we remove the
point here from the graph we still have
selected and hovered there you could do
here a more complex code or you could
reactor this saying this hashtag remove
point and now go somewhere here below
and Implement a private method for
remove
point that calls the same thing we had
before the method we implemented for the
graph also sets hovered to
n and selected to know to get the proper
interface let's refresh and now when I
remove it really goes away and no weird
artifacts
coming
now if you test this and for example
remove this
point you see it also unselected that
point any point that is selected will be
unselected because we just said this
should be null but maybe we want that
point to stay selected not make the user
have to work again if they want to
select it again for some reason so we
can easily check for that here and say
that if this
selected is that
point then we Mark selected as null we
don't have a selected Point anymore
because we removed the one that was
selected
refresh remove that and it's still
selected but if we remove this one then
it goes away and no weird artifacts are
there okay great does this work
in all possible
situations well one thing that you'll
notice is if you add a point here and
right click on it
now it doesn't remove it it doesn't go
away even after I move the mouse and
that's because we're removing points
that we hover
over our hover is updated here on Mouse
move but when we add a new point it's
not yet assigned to that point even
though our Mouse is hovering over it so
we could do that
here like
so and now creating a point and right
clicking on it will indeed remove that
point as well small things like this are
what makes a interface not just good but
really good and people will choose you
over somebody else making one now
correcting points is possible already if
we want this point to be a little bit
more to the right we just remove it and
recreate it a little bit more to the
right but dragging would make this much
easier to work with so let's add drag
functionality next and in Mouse
down when we hover over some something
here on left click I want to also enable
dragging for that
point so let's say this dragging is true
and this is going to be another
attribute
here false by
default and as we
move if we are
dragging the selected point
X and Y are going to come from our Mouse
location like
this now we also want to release of the
points somehow and I'm going to do that
with another event listener here let's
just copy the context menu and this will
be for Mouse up like
this and what we do in it
is this
dragging is false and we don't really
use this event here so we can remove it
now refresh and if I'm going to click
and
drag this works so I can add points I
can drag
points and it works just as
expected so far we've figured out the
points and it's time to move on to the
segments as well create new segments and
when building roads a very common thing
what you have to do is generate the
shape of the road like this and you
really get a lot of help if the
interface is going to generate a new
segment between the current point and
this new point that you're going to add
at each time so let's do
that we are going to go to this Mouse
down event listener and here when adding
a new point just before settings
selected to that point we're going to
use the previous value of selected if it
exists and add a segment between that
and the mouse location so I'm going to
do this
if there is a
selected let's try to add the
segment
new
segment selected at The Mouse and the
reason why I have Trad segment here is
so that I handle things like clicking on
the same point multiple times or
clicking between the points multiple
times which would otherwise add a lot of
segments that are overlapping or
invisible or something like that now
let's save refresh and if I start to
click you can see those segments added
there just
fine but maybe I would also like to add
the segment between things that exist
already like these
ones so let's copy this
code also here when just selecting
points so before this selected is set to
what is hovered we
try to add a new segment between this
selected and this hovered this
time let's save refresh and now I'm
going to select this and
this seems to work now if I'm going to
continue like
this at some point I have a problem
because maybe I want to connect these
two points next
and clicking this point or this point is
going to add a new segment here
something I don't want and the reason
for that is I have no way of unselecting
points at the
moment so if we would unselect points we
would unselect this one before clicking
on this one and then this weird segment
wouldn't happen here so maybe we go up
here when we right click and if we are
not hovering over
anything we do an
else this selected is
no okay and now I'm just going to try to
recreate a little bit that click
somewhere else with the right click and
now I can click on this point and then
this point and get the segment that I
want now the code that we have here is
pretty much the same this part and this
part is identical I'm going to implement
a method for selecting a point so this
is going to be
here a private method select point and
in it I'm going to copy one of
these and pass this point properly so
instead of mouse point
point and now up here this duplicate
from here we just remove and say this
select this
hovered and here we
say this
select
Mouse and everything should work the
same as before selecting points and
selecting
points connecting
them everything pretty
much one thing that we did before for
the points this intent showing what
happens when you click somewhere would
be really useful for the segments as
well like now we have this point
selected and if we would click here with
the left click it will connect them but
maybe we forget or maybe the user is new
and doesn't want that connection to
happen but he does it anyway then this
is going to be annoying because what the
user has to do now to undo everything is
pretty much remove this point and now
recreate oh no it selected that one
because it was already
selected remove this point click it here
and connected to
that so maybe the user just wanted to
select this like so without having
anything else selected but if they don't
see the intent that having this point
here selected is going to create a new
segment here then they don't know that
they may be surprised by what happens
and then a lot of work is
needed so I will show this intent of
creating a new segment somehow
for that we need access to where the
mouse is in the drawing section here so
I'm going to take the mouse from Mouse
move here and make it as an attribute of
the class so this mouse is going to be
that and I'm going to put this dot in
front of everywhere we use Mouse pretty
much and actually the mouse that we C
calculate here as well it's not needed
because we move the mouse before
pressing it so we're always going to
have it more or less and here this mouse
this mouse this mouse I think this is
all of them and let's define it here at
the
top and set it to n like this and with
this mouse we can
go in the display here before drawing
this selected note and let's say we
create a new
segment from this selected to this mouse
and draw it using the context save and
refresh and now when we have a point
selected you can see this line creeping
out so it does tell us that something is
going to happen there when you click
here it's going to create the segment on
that line and when you're going to click
here I would actually like this line to
snap to that point when I see that point
hovered I also want this line to appear
there as well so let's do
that we will get our
intent is the
hovered if the hovered
exists otherwise the mouse and now we
pass here this intent instead of the
mouse
refresh and now you can see that intent
jumping there but this segment that we
are drawing here as the intent looks too
much like the other ones so let's make
it look like a dashed
line I'm going to pass here
also Dash options three and three and an
array this means three pixels of line
and three pixels of space and save this
and we have to modify our segment
primitive to know to show this as well
and this starts to have again many
parameters so I'm going to group them as
an object as we did before so
Dash by default it's going to be empty
and we do this so that we can just draw
the segments without passing any of
these
parameters now the dash
here we set line Dash to the given Dash
and after we do the stroke here at the
end I like to copy this and reset the
dash so it doesn't affect all following
drawings many people like to use here uh
context save and restore at the end so
that everything gets reset but I find it
a little bit slower on my computer now
let's
test and we can see that situation from
before so anybody using this would know
that clicking here would create that but
if they right click and now click there
it selects the thing with without any
surprise
happening so if we test this a little
bit
more
aha did you spot that let's make what we
had
before here I wanted to actually select
the point that I'm
hovering and for that I did a right
click but right click didn't unselect
this one it it actually removed that
point so the priorities are different
here I would like to unselect first and
then delete deleting is
more troubling if you do the wrong thing
than having a point unselected so going
back to this graph editor I'm going to
redo the logic here for right click
let's remove
it
if it's selected we unselected else if
we are hovering over
something we remove the point that is
hovered like that save and
refresh yeah and now I can select this
one
even if I'm right clicking over
something it doesn't remove it okay test
it out let me know what do you think is
this a good interface do you want to
make it better how do you make it better
what is wrong with it write in the
comments and let's see if we can get an
even better one to work now before
moving on to something else I do want to
mention a little bit about code cleanup
here
so this ad event listeners function is
kind of long it doesn't fit on one page
that's kind of the rule make it fit on
one page so that scrolling is not needed
when looking up logic so these event
listeners for Mouse down Mouse move
could be extracted as their own
methods I'm going
to cut everything here inside of the
mouse down
event listener call back and create here
handle Mouse down private method for
this and paste inside it the previous
code now here instead of having
this Anonymous function we just say
handle Mouse down and if we save and
refresh and click it doesn't
work there's an error here and if we
press here we can see where this error
happens let's put a break point and
click
again and inspect this you can see this
here is the canvas it basically points
to the canvas but we don't want that I I
mean the canvas doesn't have a graph the
graph editor has a graph and when you
exit this scope where this referred to
the graph
editor now this inside of this function
refers to the Target of this event to
the
graph so we need to tell this function
that this should be this and the way to
do that in JavaScript is with bind
bind this and in this way it will send
this this to this
function and it's going to work again
save refresh and click and now when we
hover this it's the graph editor again
so removing the break point pressing
display the point actually appears
there and everything still works we do
the same thing also for this mouse move
so I'm just going to cut this and
Implement handle Mouse
move for the event paste this here and
here let's just
say this handle Mouse move
bind this save refresh
and everything still
works this graph editor is nice but I'd
like to make larger graphs as well and
my screen size is not that big so I'll
teach you how to make a viewport that
can be zoomed and panned around to allow
editing outside the initial region as
well it's going to be like in Photoshop
where you can draw like that
then we can really make anything we want
and it would be a shame to lose a large
graph like that so I'll teach you how to
save it so it doesn't disappear when we
refresh the page now let's begin and get
the bird's ey view of the graph we'll
initialize the
viewport here before the graph
editor like
so giving it the canvas to work
with I will also implement this in a
separate file next to this graph editor
here also in the JS
directory so let's go to
JS and
viewport JS this is also a
class and the Constructor takes the
canvas as a parameter let's store it as
an attribute like
so and let's get a reference to the to
the drawing context here as
well now the first thing we'll Implement
is the zoom and let's have an attribute
for this by default it's set to
one and add event listeners to change
the
zoom very similar structure to what we
did previous lay in the graph
editor but here we'll use different
things we're going to listen for the
mouse wheel the wheel is going to change
the
zoom so let's add an event listener to
canvas for the mouse
wheel and have a separate callback
function called handle Mouse
wheel and we bind it
to this so that it knows what this
is and let's define this handle Mouse
wheel with an event here below and let's
log this
event Delta y property and see what it
looks like in the console save refresh
and now when you scroll upward
you can see minus 125 appears on my
computer and
downwards
125 we're only interested in that sign
plus or minus so I'm going to go back
here and say the direction in which we
are going to change our Zoom is going to
be coming from this
sign like this and let's update our Zoom
with with this direction so s function
from the math library is either 1 or
minus one depending on if the value is
positive or negative and let's log here
this Zoom save refresh and now when you
scroll up you're going to get lower and
lower values when you scroll down you're
going to get higher and higher values
and I'm really only interested in this
range from one to
something maybe one to five I think
that's going to be a good range to work
with so we will disregard zero and
negative numbers and positive ones and
we want the zoom to
change slower than this so not just by
one increment each time so what we'll do
here is I'm going to define a step how
much much do we want the zoom to change
in that direction maybe
0.1 and then here the direction we can
multiply it by that step we can also cap
the zoom in a specific interval by
writing Zoom is the maximum between one
and the minimum between five and the
actual Zoom value it's a oneliner that
keeps it between 1 and five so let's
save refresh and see if it works so
scrolling up keeps it at one and going
down goes down until five so scrolling
down is going to zoom out five times
basically if that makes
sense you could keep these as attributes
like mean Zoom Max Zoom whatever I'm
just going to keep it like this because
usually you don't change these once you
implement it and it works the way you
want so let's remove now this console
log from here save this file again and
inside index HTML change the canvas
properties based on this viewport
information I'm going to go here after
clearing the rectangle and save the
state and then do a
scale with the inverse of this viewport
Zoom like
this because I want to zoom out
basically and then here restore this
save and restore are important because
this scale is going to be called on each
frame so if we don't do anything about
it it's just going to scale again and
again and again and again on top of each
other making some weird effect to happen
let's save this refresh and now when we
zoom out so I'm doing
this yeah this seems to work just fine
but um if you click somewhere like here
you're going to see that the point
doesn't come where it should come and uh
we need to fix that the way we get the
mouse should take into consideration the
zoom as well so I'm going to go to
viewport and give it away to get the
mouse information it knows what its Zoom
is so get
mouse given this event information we
return a new
Point typically we had this offset X and
Y but now we're going to multiply it by
the zoom and that's going to fix the
problem and we need to call this get
mouse in the the graph editor where we
need the mouse information the mouse
location so the graph editor needs to
know about this viewport not about the
canvas I'm going to change the way that
we initialize it here with the viewport
and that means we have to go in graph
editor JS in the Constructor here change
this to be a viewport viewport viewport
and the canvas which we do need is going
to come from the
viewport like
that now here where we get this mouse
information we just take
it from this viewport get
mouse using this event information
refresh and now zoom out a bit and when
we
click it works as
expected one thing that we should fix at
this point is when you zoom out a lot
like that it becomes really difficult to
click on the points here you have to be
very very close so this threshold here
of 10 gets shrunk because of this zoom
out F so you want an Adaptive threshold
basically and you can fix that by
multiplying here with the zoom as well
what happens now when we refresh and
zoom out a bit you can
see that point starts to be
hovered when we are closer than 10
pixels away from it but we're not really
hovering it we just get close to it the
same distance that we had previously
making it much easier to interact with
those points but maybe we don't want
this maybe we do want to um have zoomed
in view like this when editing to be
more precise and now just drag to go to
that part of the space where the points
are and we're going to implement drag
also using the mouse wheel but we're
going to click on it and drag by holding
the mouse wheel
so this middle button will control the
offset of the
viewport let's define this offset
at the top and by default it's going to
be Z 0 and we're going to need also a
way to store the drag information we're
going to be dragging the viewport and we
need to know where we started where we
ended and compute some kind of
differences and add them into the
offset
like
so and I'm also going to add here a way
to know if we are actively dragging or
not then this event listener for Mouse
wheel we're going to copy
it three more times so that we have one
for
Mouse down handle Mouse
down
Mouse move handle Mouse
move and mouse up handle
Mouse up and we Define these below here
as
well so handle Mouse
down given the event it's going to first
check is it the middle Mouse button that
we are pressing is it this one not these
other two because then it would
interfere with the graph
editor so if event button is one this is
the middle
button then we set the start of the drag
to this get
mouse EVT this get mouse will have the
correct information no matter what the
zoom level
is then we also say that the drag has
started has been
activated now on Mouse
move we will only do
something if this drag is
active and we will calculate the end
location of the current action so the
current Mouse location pretty much and
I'm going to to write this in this end
attribute
here this get mouse EVT so start and end
are different after the drag has started
and you continue to move the mouse and
from start to end that gives you the
offset of your current drag and I'm
going to store that offset here you just
calculate the difference and this is
going to use vectors the difference
between the drag end and the drag start
so this Vector essentially you can
imagine it starting at drag start and
ending at drag end it tells you how much
the offset will change when you release
the mouse which is the next thing that
we'll
do the mouse up event
handler if we are inside of an active
drag
again we
add to the existing
offset the drag
offset and we also reset the drag
information here so what we have here at
the top this drag is equal to that I'm
just going to past it
here like so and we need to implement
these simple Vector operations
here so math
utils I'm going to go here below this
distance and
say add P1 and
P2 return new point where we just add
the X and add the Y and for subtract I'm
just going to copy that
subtract and put here minus
minus and everything's going to work but
we still need to use this offset
somewhere so here in index
HTML after we
scale we are going to also
translate viewport offset
X viewport offset y save the file
refresh the page and now I'm going to
press the middle Mouse
button move it here and release the
middle Mouse button and when I do that
the drag has happened but of course you
would like to see the drag as it's
happening so you want to get the
cumulative offset of the current drag
action and the stored offset information
this works otherwise I'm now going to
drag everything back and like this and
like that and some interfaces do work
like this they don't show the current
action to keep the processor usage low
but nowadays pretty much everybody
expects to see what is really happening
at a glance so I'm going to take this
offset including the drag
and I'm going to have the viewport
computed for me so get offset will add
viewport offset and the viewport drag
offset together and here we just keep
this so going to viewport
JS below get mouse we will also have get
offset which adds this
offset the this drag offset like this
now save this refresh and as I'm
dragging you can see the motion like
this and you can feel it a little bit
lagging
here and that's because our animation
Loop here reenders itself pretty much 60
frames per second but your mouse
movement is a little bit faster than
that so you can see the location of the
points dragging a bit and you could get
a faster interface update if you link
this rendering to
the mouse move event but I prefer to use
this animation Loop here because at the
end there will be things in this world
that animate like the car movement and
and whatever so this structure here is
more in line with what we did in phase
one of of the
course now zooming out here bothers me a
little bit because I'm very used for the
zooming to happen from the center
somehow not the top left corner so if my
object is here and I'm going to zoom in
now I expect to keep it in
frame and it doesn't happen so we need
to consider where the center of the
viewport is as
well I'm going to go to viewport JS at
the top and above this offset let's
get a reference to the center point of
the canvas so half the canvas width and
half the
canvas
height and now in index
HTML before we do the scale so the
original width and height of the canvas
is going to
be what it is and not affected by the
scale we
translate to this Center at first save
and refresh and you'll see that things
have moved that way by half the canvas
width and half the canvas height so this
point here is now 0
0 if we drag everything in the middle
though and zoom out and in like this we
do get what we want so what we need to
do is this initial offset that we have
in the beginning it should be directed
that way by how much this Center is
offset so we're going to go to viewport
JS here and our offset here is actually
going to be equal to
scale this
Center by minus one so basically it's
going to be a point with minus canvas
width / two and minus canvas height
divided by two but now I have an
opportunity to implement this scale
function for vectors here in
utils it's a little bit different than
add and subtract because it takes the
point as a parameter and the second
parameter is a scaler it's a simple
number it's not a point with X and Y
and what we do with it is
just
multiply both P of X and P of Y like
this save and refresh and now the
initial view is
correct zooming out and zooming
in is as
expected
but clicking is not so now we have to
consider also the offset when we
calculate the mouse location in the
viewport
here we do that by subtracting
here this offset X and here this offset
y and here we also have to consider that
Center information as well so I'm going
to put in
parenthesis minus Center this is
before stretching it with the with the
zoom and the same happens
here with the
center y like that save and refresh and
now let's zoom and move somewhere and
when when we click everything seems to
work and you can now edit these points
by zooming in and working on different
parts of the
screen H but now this
intent doesn't show well you can see how
while I'm dragging here something
strange happens to this intent to this
line it's fine when I'm not dragging
it's always at the mouse location but if
I start here and move to the right a
little bit it seems to go to the right
even more and same happens like this the
mouse is always in the middle of the
starting point where we began the
dragging
here and whatever the
current tip of that dotted line is there
so what we want to do is actually subtra
ract the drag offset in this
case and I'm going to go to graph editor
here where we get the mouse and say that
yes we want the mouse by subtracting the
drag offet so this get mouse needs an
update here where we subtract that drag
offset so this is going to be false by
default we like this functionality all
the time
except while we are doing the drag there
so here instead of return we are going
to
say Point
p is the new point and what we return is
depending on this second parameter if
it's true then we do subtract from P
this drag offset otherwise it's just p
as
before save this
refresh and now if we select something
and
drag we can see that it's always still
pointing at the mouse apart from that
small delay caused by the animation
tuop yeah this is quite
good but what we really need to take
care of is
here this animate function is really
getting complicated and all of this kind
of functionality should be really taken
care of um by the
viewport the problem is we have this
graph editor display wrapped between the
restore and everything else and one way
to solve this problem is actually move
it at the dop so the restore happens
before the save and if you think about
it it does make sense so now all this
code from here before this is going to
be cut I'm going to cut it and it's
still there it's in my clipboard so
don't lose it and we're going to just
call
viewport reset so we reset the viewport
and then we
display now this reset functionality I'm
going to implement it
here and say
reset let's just paste
everything
and CTX will not be recognized so we
have to say this dot CTX pretty much
everywhere where we see
CTX and my canvas it is a global
variable but we have our own
local one that we can
use like this and viewport here it's
just this so this this this this and
this
save refresh and now everything should
still work as
before
but the code is much cleaner and now you
are free to make any size graph you
want and um might be useful to have a
way to save this and this is not really
a great graph here so maybe also
removing it a button that deletes
everything so let's have two buttons
here for the save and for removing
everything otherwise you'd have to right
click click a lot and you don't want to
do that in these kind of
situations we're going to go to index
HTML where our controls were in the very
beginning and let's define a
button it will
dispose of the
graph and I'm going to copy this the
other one will be save
and these buttons will stay there in the
end so I'm going to style them a little
bit better I'm going to use emojis and
this is just a trash can emoji and this
one here it's going to be the save Emoji
so this dispose function let's implement
it here
below
dispose and it's going to tell the
graphic Editor to dispose itself and the
reason I do this is that here inside of
the graph editor
now Above This display it's going to
have another public method called
dispose and in it we tell the graph to
dispose but we also want to reset hover
then select it so I'm going to say
selected is null and hovered is null
like that that's it for this pose so
let's go back to index HTML and also
handle the save function this one is
just going to store the current version
of the graph in local storage so local
storage set item the
graph and I will use Json stringify to
convert the graph into a string because
local storage only works with
strings let's
save refresh and let's try
dispose seems to work and let's create a
new graph
here maybe just going to
say
hi and save it now when we save it we
should be able to see it here inside of
local storage get
item
graph like this we see the points and
the and the segments just fine but when
we
refresh the old one comes again the one
with the hardcoded values even
though the one we stored is still there
so we just need to load this information
inside of the graph instead of the
hardcoded
values I'm going to go back here and
let's remove these hardcoded things from
here leave this as an empty
graph for now and what we do is we check
to see is there this string information
inside of the local
storage and if there is we get the info
object containing the points
and the segments by parsing it using
Json
parse or it's null if the local storage
doesn't contain the
graph and now here the graph will either
be what is in graph info or this one if
graph info is null so let's
say graph
info and if it exists we have
have a new graph with the points and the
segments from graph info so we load that
original graph that is stored in local
storage save and
refresh it doesn't work the problem is
the things that we have in local storage
here are just objects called points and
segments but they are not really points
and segments
in the same way that we expect them to
be they don't have for example a draw
method this is all they have so we need
to convert this information
into points and segment
objects I'm going to do that by using
um static method called
load that we're going to add to the
graph given some information it's going
to create a graph for us so in graph JS
below the Constructor let's define it
here static load info so we call this
function with capital graph as you seen
here and this function belongs to the
class not to the instances like all the
other ones and what we do in it is we
prepare our point
and our
segments with the information from this
info so I'm going to get the point
information of each individual point
from the info points and just say push a
new
point with Point info X and point info y
so what happens now is I'm generating a
point with the same information from the
Json
object and same thing with the segment
as well segment info of info
segments segments push new
segment segment info P1 segment info P2
like this and now with this information
we can return a new
graph like this so it's not just passing
in info points and info segments but
actual points and segment objects in two
different arrays let's save refresh and
look at that just as we
expected JavaScript is killing me with
this uh serialization stuff to be
honest the problem
is these p P1 and P2
points are not points they are again
objects that have an X and Y but they
are not the same points from here even
though they should
be so we have to take care of that I'm
going to remove these from here and we
need to find in this
points array the same points that
correspond to P1 and P2 from the Json
info so let's
find point that was equal to this P1 in
the list of points that we created and
also P2 like so save and
refresh and now everything looks as
expected I really don't like that you
have to do so much work to get this to
work but it is what it is if you know a
better way of doing this do let me know
actually I know a better way of doing
this we can refactor a little bit and
say here for example the
points we can just use the map method
and go through each point I and create a
new one so this I stands for Json info
and we create new points using that
information in one line so we don't need
this for Loop
anymore and we can even do the same
thing for the segments as well so the
info segments we can remap them to
actual segments each segment I is going
to be a new
segment and here we just paste this
information like
so and make sure that this seg info is
high
now and we don't need this second for
Loop anymore so a little bit more
concise save refresh and everything
still works it's just a little bit nicer
structure
here we could design the road border now
like this but it kind of looks like a
child made them making sure Road borders
have the same thickness everywhere is
important and not fun so today I'll
teach you how to use geometry to wrap
the graph segments in what I'm going to
call envelopes they're just polygons
with more points here to make them look
round we then compute the union of these
polygons to keep just the outer segments
this solution keeps the number of clicks
to a minimum and makes the World
building very satisfying I think now
let's get this show on the
road I'm going to draw a simple
graph that kind of looks like the letter
J save it and now let's Implement a
functionality that creates a polygon
using these
points we're going to test this
functionality here after displaying the
graph
editor like so creating a new polygon
with the graph
points and drawing it on the context so
we need to implement a polygon and give
it the draw method same as the other
Primitives speaking of which the polygon
is also going to be a primitive
here and let's create the
file
polygon
JS now the polygon is also a simple
class and in the
Constructor I'm going to pass the
points and store them as an
attribute like so and the draw method
I'm going to give it the context and
some options with uh default stroke
set to Blue and the line width of two
and I want it to be transparent let's
set it to a
transparent
blue fail style like
this now inside of the draw method We
Begin the
path we set the fil style to the fill
attribute the stroke style to the
stroke and the line withd to the line
WID Now we move
to the first point like
this and use a for
Loop to essentially create line
to all the other points one by one until
we've connected all of
them so CTX line
to points of
i x and points of I of Y like this and
now we close the
path this will draw the line back to the
first point and then and I want to fill
and also stroke this
time let's save and refresh the page and
now we get this so the graph is still
there but now we also see this polygon
this blue polygon on top of the graph
points and if I'm going to add some more
points
here and play a little bit with these
points maybe connect these ones you can
see the graph starts to appear here in
the
middle but the polygon and the graph are
two different things it's not the same
kind of structure the graph can have
these branching elements here now the
next thing I want to do is create a
polygon
along one of these graph segments so
somehow enveloping it in a polygon and
and we're going to do that by creating
another object called
envelope and it's going to be
used like this new
envelope graph segments of zero the
first segment and let's give this a
width and the width of 80 pixels and
draw it on the context like so as before
we Define here another
primitive
envelope in
our
envelope
JS class
envelope and the Constructor is going to
take the parameter of the segment and
I'm going to refer to this as skeleton
it's like the inside of the envelope and
the second parameter is going to be the
width of this envelope let's store this
skeleton as an
attribute and we'll use the width to
generate the
polygon like so in a private method
called generate
polygon like
this now we're going to be working with
the points of this skeleton and I don't
want to type this skeleton P1 this
skeleton P2 all the time so I'll just
use the destructuring
assignment like this and now we can just
use B1 and B2 we also need the
radius half of the
width and the angle between P1 and P2
two we can get it with ar tangent 2
method between the difference of those
points like
that now we're going to need an angle
that is offset by 90° and actually
offset 90° clockwise and
counterclockwise so I'm going to refer
to that
angle like this and just add half pi to
Al Al and let's copy this below and say
here Alpha
counterclockwise and put a minus here
for minus
90° and now we can start to get points
that are offset so from P1 we are going
to get a point P1
CCW offset
counterclockwise by
translating P1 according to Alpha CC W
by the radius this is going to be the
offset that we move it along the angle
from this given point B1 we're going to
need to implement this translate method
but I'm just going to first use it here
to define the other similar points P2
CCW coming from
P2 and then P2
CW coming from P2 and Alpha CW and P1 CW
coming from P1 Alpha CW like this and
these are the points that we will use to
create our polygon
so we return a new polygon with this
array of
points like so let's implement this
Translate method and maybe we'll also
extract this angle function because this
is kind of cryptic here like if you
don't know the formula what is this
doing so inside of math and utils I'm
going to go here at the bottom and
Implement our translate
method which returns a new point
relative to the given location we add
and now we have to use the trigonometric
Circle and remember that on the X it's
the
coine of the angle and we multiplied
this cosine by the offset how much we
want to move it because cosine is
between 0 and 1 so multiplying this is
going to move the
point
a total of
offset on X and Y respectively so
diagonally now that angle function is
going to be really easy given a point we
just output its
angle like this and back here we can
replace this with angle and then we can
just subtract the two points because
that's what this is doing so let's put
here
angle subtract P1
P2 and to draw the envelope we also need
to give it a draw method
here and for now this is just going to
tell the polygon to draw itself now save
this and
refresh and we get this you can see now
this polygon
forming surrounding only the first
segment of the graph the others are
ignored for now but I want this polygon
to have curved sides like that here
surrounding this because round roads are
just
nicer so let's figure out how to do that
here I'm going to first collect some
points around
P1 I do that by defining here an array
called points and now let's loop from
alpha
counterclockwise to Alpha
clockwise and increase this I with a
step we'll Define that in a
second and then push into this
points translating P1 at this I
angle by the
radius and this step is going to be a
fraction
of Pi actually I like to use Pi when
dealing with circles and let's try to
see what these points look like so I'm
going to pass here points instead and we
really don't need these other variables
they were just there to learn how this
works save and
refresh and now we get this we get some
kind of curviness here we can actually
control this by this value if we put
here 10 for
example we're going to get a much more
curvy shape and let's do the same thing
with P2 as well so I'm going to copy
this
below and this doesn't change but here
we are going to use
P2 and it's on the opposite side so
180° difference and I'm going to add
here matte pi plus I like this and save
refresh and now we get
this this is actually a parameter how
round we want this shape to be and we
could replace this with
roundness and here let's pass it as
parameter roundness and I'm going to
pass it also here and here maybe give it
a default value of something let's try
let's try what happens with zero like
zero
roundness this doesn't really look
good let's try
one it's what we had previously and this
is actually what I would assume to have
if the roundness is zero as well so I'm
going to go here and do this kind of
trickery to avoid that zero situation
because it doesn't make any sense and
now when we set zero
here it's actually going to look like
one
so when moving it like this there seems
to be some problem and it happens
because here sometimes I doesn't exactly
reach Alpha uncore CW this happens
because how floating Point numbers work
and sometimes you just get a value that
is below that and the next value adding
step exceeds feeds that so it never hits
exactly there and then you're far from
this end result we can fix this by
adding a small Epsilon value and I'm
making it here a fraction of the step we
add this Epsilon value
here to this and in that way we
guarantee that we include this final
angle there and we don't go overboard
because it's just half a step in this
case so I'm going to save this refresh
and now no more strange artifacts like
that
coming I'm going to keep this default
roundness here to one because it somehow
makes sense you can create an envelope
without a roundness and we can play with
the parameters here as well if we want
maybe set a width of 200 and let's give
it a roundness of 20 see how it looks
like okay really round large shape
there now I really want to generate
these envelopes for everything and it's
time to start thinking about defining
our world object the one that will
contain the roads and all the other
components there because these envelopes
are going to be part of what is required
to build that world so let's implement
this world object containing all the
things and in there have a way to
generate all the envelopes for all the
graph
segments I'm going to go here below this
graph definition
and instantiate the world with the graph
the world will be based on this graph
and now I want this world to
automatically update every time we
change some things every time we edit
the graph and I'm going to add this call
here to generate the world and also to
draw the world and I'm doing it before
the graph editor because it's going to
contain things and I want to still see
the editing tools on top of that let's
now
import a new file called
World JS and this is going to be here in
the root JS directory so next to the
editor and the
viewport and the class is going to be
also relatively simple for now it's
going to become quite complex by the end
of this course I'm going to pass here
some default parameters like the road
width and
roundness and let's store
these things as
attributes as
well and
roundness and now I want to store these
envelopes to generate these
envelopes uh we will generate them in
this class attribute which is empty by
default
and the
generation will happen here we generate
them with this generate method and if
they're already generated because we do
this in a in a loop in in the animation
Loop we empty this array to begin with
because we are going to regenerate them
again and again on each frame maybe we
change the editor and then we want the
changes to reflect in the world that we
create so let's Loop through all the
segments
now like this and push into this
envelopes array a new
envelope
from this seg
and with the road width and Road
roundness attributes from above and now
this world is also going to need a draw
method and I am just going to for now
Loop through all of these
envelopes and draw
them on the context one by one let's
refresh and now we get
this
um funny to play with
this reminds me a little bit of this uh
quop game I made in uh live stream
once all
right now the thing we need to deal with
next are these sections here these kind
of inter sections between these
envelopes they need to somehow disappear
and all of these envelopes should form a
union a single shape that doesn't have
any kind of overlapping Parts the first
step in that is actually detecting these
intersecting points all these small
intersecting points between the
envelopes and we are going to do that
for the first two envelopes to begin
with maybe I remove this part from here
and save a simpler version of the graph
to avoid confusion so let's find all
these intersecting points here
somehow we'll store these
intersections here in an
attribute and the function that will do
this is called break it's going to be a
static method inside of the polygon
class and it's going to take two
polygons and break them you'll see what
that means soon enough but it will
return these intersections that I was
talking about so here we are going to
draw also these intersections after the
envelopes maybe
int int and this intersections here and
and they will appear on the canvas after
we implement this break method let's go
to polygon JS and it would be useful to
have the segments of this polygon as
well the sides of the polygon having
them readily available here is going to
make implementing the brake function
easier so in the Constructor I will also
get the
segments by
looping starting at one through all the
points like this and pushing into the
segments
array a new
segment between the previous
point and the current point and I want
this to Loop so when I is going to be
equal to points do length then points of
I would return an error but doing this
is going to return the remainder when
dividing by that so this will jump to
zero instead of giving an error and
that's going to loop around and connect
back to the first point which is what we
want to have that segment as well and
now we can Implement that static method
called break that takes two poies poly
one and poly two and really only uses
the segments of those
so let me just take poly one
segments and poly
two segments like this and now Define
the
intersections that we want to
find and find them by looping through
all the segments of the first
polygon and for each segment we check to
see if it intersect any segment of the
second polygon so we need this other for
Loop here as
well and
then we get the
intersection
between
P1 P2 of the first segment
and
P1
P2 of the second
segment and
then we check here if the intersection
exists because sometimes segments don't
intersect and if the offset is different
from one and different from zero this
means that they don't intersect exactly
at the tip
which is a situation we want to avoid
then we get the
point from this intersection object
you'll see that in a second and
push to the
intersections this point and then return
intersections like this now I'm going to
go to utils JS and add this get
intersection function and I'm just going
to go down here and paste so this
function I'm not going to explain I
already have a special video about it
and it was part of phase one of the
self-driving car course so if you took
phase one then you already know what
this is it also includes this linear
interpolation function which I also have
a video about and we also Al used in
phase one I will link to this code
somewhere in the description so you can
copy it now but let's see if it
works and it does show some points here
let's make them a little different
looking so we don't confuse them with
the graph points so here when we draw
the intersection I'm going to say color
it red and uh make it smaller I think
the red color is enough
striking and now we get
this
yep seems like it
works and what we'll do next is we're
not done with this break method here it
doesn't just create the intersections
but it's also going to break break these
segments so that for example this
segment here on the side of this
envelope is going to be divided into
this segment and this segment after that
we're going to take the segments that
are contained inside of another envelope
and remove them that's how we're going
to do the cleaning so let's do this
breaking at this intersection
Point here after after we have this
intersection
point I'm going
to keep a reference to P2 of Segment
1 and replace P2 of Segment 1 with this
so what we did now is instead of having
this large segment we just replaced the
end point to be here this space here is
empty and we need to create create a new
segment that starts now here and ends at
that place that's why we kept the
reference to the original P2 we need to
use it now and we do that by using
splice at I + one so the next segment
and we don't remove anything splice
expects here how many things to remove
from the array we don't want to remove
anything we want to add a new
segment starting at the
intersection and
until what was P2 previously and we do
this also for the other segment where
the intersection
happened so I'm going to copy this
without this let because I just want to
reassign this auxiliary variable to
something else and this is going to be
seg 2 of
J and SE 2 of J SE 2 splice at j+ one
and this should work but we need a good
way to test this and I'm going to do
that here I will Implement a way to draw
the segments by using different colors
and in that way we know if it's the same
segment that continues after the
intersection point or something else so
going through all the segments I will
draw them on the
context with the
color get random color and this let's go
to utils again I'm going to paste
something again we used it in Phase One
to draw cars in different
colors let's also go to envelope
JS here and after we draw the poy
normally I'm also going to draw segments
with this debugging function we just
implemented so
refresh and now we get this crazy thing
with a lot of colors going around let's
make these segments wider I think they
are not very visible as such so I'm
going to pass here inside of the polygon
JS draw segment
also
um width of
five now
refresh looks a little better I'm
actually going to remove the
intersections we don't need them anymore
we know they work and actually this
breake function doesn't need to collect
and return the intersections it just
needs to break the polygons so I'm going
to remove this part from here here as
well it uses the get intersection
function but it doesn't collect the
points we don't need that and inside of
world JS I'm going to
stop using the intersections there
refresh and things move a lot but you
can kind of tell that this color here is
not the same as this color here and here
there are quite many small changes as
well you can debug this better by typing
debugger in the console and this is
going to instantaneously stop what is
happening here and you can see this
green red orange and pinkish color here
and a lot of these small changes here
every time something intersects so the
code seems to
work but only for the first two
envelopes if I'm going to draw here
another one you can see
this segment here is not affected this
segment here is not affected and same
for the small ones here so this is the
difference what we did now breaking the
polygon segments at the intersection
points contrary to what we have on the
right and what we're going to do next is
do the same thing on the right and for
every possible combination of
envelopes instead of having here polygon
break we are going to remove this line
and have polygon multi
break and I will take all
the
polies from all the envelopes and send
as a parameter one
array now this multi Brak inside of
polygon JS let's add it here at the
top is a static method
that gets this array of
Poes and I'm just going to
Loop through the
polies excluding the last
one and then for each of these Poes loop
again starting at i+ one so I'm not
going to compare Poes twice I'm just
going to compare
every poly with all that follow
afterwards and that means we don't do
unnecessary
work and this one will go all the way
until the
end and now we use the previous method
break between Poes of I and Poes of J
like this and if we save and refresh
let's add again this other segment here
and call here
debugger we can see now that this
intersection is
breaking everywhere as it should and
what we'll do next is calculate a union
of all the segments that are not inside
some other envelope so this segment will
disappear this will disappear this will
disappear this small one here will
disappear these will disappear because
they're in this envelope and these will
disappear because they're also in this
envelope these disappear because they're
in this envelope so everything that is
inside some envelope will
disappear and the result from this will
just be a set of segments that we keep
it will not be a polygon anymore because
for example the resulting shape here
would actually be a polygon it would
start like this and go like this around
and then have a concavity here but if
you think about this shape here it would
be a polygon that also has a hole and
that's a more complex structure and I
don't want to get into
that so let's Implement our Union
function maybe we save this graph as
well and
here we start off
this Union
process with the given Poes with a multi
break so we break them to get the
individual segments and now let's
collect the segments that we wish to
keep in this array I'm going to scroll
down because this is going to be a
longer
function so looping through all of the
polies one by one
one and now looping through
all of the segments of a given
poly we have to figure out if we keep
this segment or not so I'm going to say
keep is true for now but if this segment
is inside another envelope another
polygon here then we don't keep it so
let's Loop through the Poes again
through all of
them but ignore
here the
situation when I is equal to J so we
don't want to check if a segment is
inside of its polygon it makes no sense
and in that case when it's different
then we check if it does
contain this segment
if one of these Poes contains this
segment this seg right here then we
don't keep it anymore we say keep is
false and we can break here to save some
computational time because it could be
inside several
envelopes and here if we keep then I'm
going to push it to the kept segments
like so and at the end here we return
these kept segments so it's a longish
function but um it is what it is I'm not
going to refactor it
anymore what we need to do next is
implement this contains segment function
so how do we check if this segment is
inside something else and because these
segments that are in inside are entirely
inside something else I'm going to
simplify this and only work with the
middle point of the segment so the
average of the endpoint locations
here what that means is that this
contain segment is going to
transfer its
functionality to another method called
contains point which is a simpler thing
to do now this is not really a great
implementation
because sometimes the segment may be
just partially inside but for our needs
it's going to be okay the only problem
is the name of this method right here
contains segment is a little bit
misleading because it only checks if the
midpoint is contained inside it and the
average function here it's just a simple
thing that we add quickly here in utils
let's move it next to the other point
Vector
operations so average of two
points I'm just going to return
here new Point p1x + p2x ided by 2 and
P1 y + P2 y / by two like
this and now we can go back and
implement the content
Point
algorithm for this we're going to need
an outer point that outer point I'm just
going to Define as a point that is far
away in the top left maybe minus 1,000
minus 1,000 I just hope nobody goes
there and draws the graph in that area
it's going to make some small glitches
happen I guess and then what we're going
to do is we're going to check how many
times this line segment from point to
this outer Point intersects the
polygon if it intersects one time then
it means that we are inside but polygons
can be quite complex shapes sometimes
this line segment may cross it multiple
times maybe it goes outside and then
inside again and then outside again but
if it's always going to be an odd number
of times then that means that we are
still inside the polygon if it's an even
number of times it means we're outside
of the polygon we just crossed it to go
in and then out then we reach this outer
point and even number of
intersections so that's how the
algorithm is going to go I'm going to
Define here
intersection
count set it to zero
and go through all the segments of this
polygon and
calculate the number of
intersections from Outer point
point to P1 and P2 of this segment and
if there is this
intersection I'm going to increase the
intersection
count like this and at the end we just
return if the intersection
count if the remainder when dividing by
two is zero then this doesn't contain
the point because it's even but if it's
one then this does contain the point so
we are done with our method
now to test we need to
assign these new segments to some object
here and I'm going to call
this road
borders like so and here we are going to
say Road borders is equal to
polygon
Union of all the
Poes and in the draw method I'm going to
Loop through all of the segments of this
road
borders and draw
them under
context maybe we give them some clearer
style here let's give a white color
and a width of four so the line is
thicker let's save refresh fresh and now
you can see here these white sections
are only on the outsides of the
envelopes let's set um larger roundness
maybe
10 and now you can see these white
sections are here curving quite nicely
around this
shape let's Style this to look more like
a road I'm going to make the envelopes
um gray let's remove also this crazy
colorful highlighting there
so the envelopes here I'm going to style
them with the
fill of BBB so this is light gray and
the stroke is going to be also the same
this means we have to pass options to
the envelope draw method as well because
it doesn't have them at the moment so
options and let's pass these to the poly
so that it's going to use the same
options and we don't need this draw
segments anymore for the colorful
highlighting
refresh and now it looks like this and
you can play around with it and see that
it does behave quite nicely as you would
expect but I would like to add a little
bit more of a region here that is gray
so that this white border of the road is
not exactly on the border of the road
but the road continues just a little bit
it's just a marking to do that I'm going
to go back here and give also um line
width of
maybe 15 to the
envelopes and now we see here this
margin like that and I would also like
to draw the mid lines on the road as
dashed lines so for that we're going to
go
here and loop through all of the
segments of the
graph and draw each
segment also with white and also maybe
for and a dash of 10
10 save
refresh and something happens here but
this um graph editor is blocking and I
can't really see what is happening maybe
we go to index
HTML and um let's try commenting out
this graph
editor yeah and uh graph editor actually
still
works even without displaying the the
things there so you could leave it like
this but I don't like it I don't get
those intense marked in any way like if
I'm hovering something or what is going
to happen when I click here uhuh
something weird happened I didn't know
that because I don't have my editor
anymore so I will remove this and I will
just go here and add um transparency for
the editor I think that this is going to
be
enough so now I still see it but it's
not anymore the main thing
there the roads are more emphasized
we're going to add some decorative items
next the buildings and the trees and
we'll just focus on the basis first
fancy stuff comes later now with few
modifications we could use the same
graph editing tools to generate the
bases of the buildings as well but I
think it's really tedious as especially
if you plan to build really big worlds
and if you want things to align just
right so we'll reuse the functionalities
we already have and Implement an
algorithm to procedurally generate
buildings next to the roads and then
just Place trees randomly where they fit
this solution does have a downside that
you cannot have a building exactly the
way you want it but I think it really
compensates for that because generating
everything becomes so fast and easy that
you actually could build Rome in one
day let's go to world
JS and here in the Constructor add some
more properties for generating buildings
I'm going to align these a little bit
different because there will be quite
many things appearing
here first one is the building
width and then the building minimum
length the length will vary depending on
the size of the road
segment I want to have a minimum value
and in this case setting it the same as
the building width means that in the
worst case we will have a square
building otherwise it's just going to go
alongside the road and the spacing is so
buildings don't get stuck to each other
now let's set these values here as
attributes of the
world like so building
width to minimum
length and the
spacing and let's store the
buildings
here in this array
now we'll generate the buildings inside
of the generate function
here by typing buildings is equal to
this generate buildings we'll write all
the functionality in this private method
the algorithm will go like this we first
generate some thicker envelopes and use
the same processes before to get the
outer segments from these we keep those
is long enough to support at least one
building and if they're really long we
divide them into multiple supports like
this we then generate a poly around each
of these using envelopes again and do a
little bit of fine tuning you'll
see
generate buildings let's first get these
thicker
envelopes I'm just going to call them
temporary envelopes because we don't
need them
afterwards from the graph segments we
take each segment one by one and create
an envelope using it and push it to this
temporary envelopes so the envelope that
we're going to create has the segment as
the skeleton but then the width we have
to calculate so it's going to be the
Road
width and then I'm going to add here the
building
width and then the
spacing twice and finally the roundness
I'm just going to use the same one from
the
road now let's return these envelopes
for now these are not buildings just yet
they here just envelopes but we will use
the result of this method and the
contents of this buildings array to
debug and we are going to display now
those envelopes even though here I'm
already going to
WR as if they are
buildings save and
refresh and we see this it's uh not
really clear but um these are some
thicker envelopes than the ones used to
define the road so next step is to avoid
these inner segments here so we do the
union of these envelope
poies
here and those remaining segments will
be guides I will refer to them as guides
here and they will be computed by doing
the Union on these temporary
envelopes so I map
here just the
police let's paste this here and
debug and now you can see these guides
appearing
here as segments this
time and the buildings are going to be
generated on them but not on all all of
them only if the guide is longer than
the minimum length of the building so
let's filter out these very small
segments here in the curvy areas and
anything that is too short to support
the
building we are going to Loop through
the guides that we
have
let's just take it here like
so and if the length of this segment is
less than the minimum length of the
building then we are going to remove
that I will remove the guide at
I one of them and then we also have to
do I minus minus here because when
removing something from an array it's
going to shift everything over this so
then the index at I where we are will
have some new item that also needs to be
checked so if we let I increase which it
will for the next step it's going to
skip that one unless we decrease as well
now this segment here we need the way to
calculate its length and it's really
easy we just go to The Primitives
segment and Implement a length method
here that will just return the
distance between this P1 and this P2 now
we can save and
refresh and you can see it looks
different these are the only places
where buildings can appear in this
scenario The Next Step will be to
generate the supports for those
buildings so for example this segment
here is quite long and it's probably
going to
support multiple buildings and I want to
get small segments that we can use as a
way to define the buildings around them
using envelopes again you'll see now
let's say that we could fit three
buildings here I want them to start from
here and here and also have the spacing
in between and the logic for what we're
going to implement next is going to be
much easier I if we consider a little
bit of extra spacing at the end as well
because then we can think of a building
as the building and its spacing the
building and its spacing the building
and its spacing and that will help in
writing the
code so let's go back to World JS here
and Define these
supports that we need to calculate
next and loop through all the segments
of the guides and for each segment let's
calculate that length with a little bit
of extra spacing
there so it's the length of the segment
plus this
spacing and now we can find out how many
buildings would fit so the building
count is going to be ma.
floor of the length divided
by this building minimum length plus
this
spacing and now that we know how many
buildings there are we can find out what
is the actual length of the buildings so
the buildings on this segment will have
a length equal to the length of this
total segment with the extra spacing
divided by the building
count but now we have the building and
the spacing included in this length so
let's subtract this spacing as well and
we can proceed to generate the supports
along this segment with this building
length that we
calculated so to do that I'm first going
to focus on the first support so let's
get the direction of this segment we're
going to
needed and then two points q1 is going
to be segment
B1 and Q2 is going to be according to
segment q1 we move along this direction
the length of this building length so
what we're going to do is add to
q1 scaling this direction vector
by the building length and add this
segment to
the
supports like so let's implement this
direction Vector it's also easy going to
be
calculated by
normalizing because I don't want this
vector Vector to contain any magnitude
any distance really it's going to have a
distance of one a magnitude of one and
we just get it by
subtracting P1 from P2 like this so this
is going to be the vector from P1 to P2
and it's going to be normalized so it's
just the direction there this
normalization we don't have it
implemented just yet but it's easy to do
we just go to
utils and maybe here below the
scale we normalize
P by just scaling p with the inverse of
its length of its magnitude and now this
magnitude it's just the distance to the
origin so I'm going to implemented using
the hypotenuse there and I'm only going
to pass X and Y because the difference
is X and Y the other point is the origin
and
refresh I have a typo
here World JS
floor
refresh and now it works looks pretty
much same as before but if we make one
segment
longer it doesn't work I forgot to pass
here the supports to the return
as
well okay now if we make this segment
longer you can see that only the first
support for the buildings along this
line is shown and same happens
here so let's do the other
ones we just Loop here starting from the
second building until we reach the
building
count and update these q1 and Q2 so q1
is going to become
Q2 but we add the
spacing in the direction of the
direction
vector and Q2 is going to be q1 now but
we
add in the direction Vector the length
of the building this
time and
we add a new
support segment between q1 and Q2 let's
save this
refresh and
now we can see these supports for the
buildings appearing there let's generate
the base for each of them using the
envelope with no roundness we are going
to get a rectangular Reg there a
polygon so here after we're done with
these supports I'm going to
write
bases like this and looping through all
of the
supports I'm going to push a new
envelope from this segment with the
building
width as a width no roundness because
it's going to default to just a
rectangular shape and then I take from
here the polygon I don't want to use
envelopes here I just want the polygon
I'm using the envelope Constructor to
get the polygon that I want pretty much
and now let's remember to return these
bases and
refresh
yeah
this looks nice but here there are some
intersecting bases
and I'm just going to remove one of them
if this happens so let's go back here
and say
looping between all pairs of bases to
find those that intersect if some of
them intersect I'm going to Loop through
all all of them except for the last one
and now all following ones so starting
with j at I + one and going until the
Bas is length to include the final one
as well and now we check to see if bases
of I intersects the poly bases of J and
if it does I'm going to
remove let's say basis of J because it's
the second forward Loop there and
decrease from the second for Loop
because of the same issue mentioned
previously now this intersects poly we
need to implement and we're going to go
in polygon
JS somewhere here maybe and type
intersects
poly a given poly and we're going to
look through all of these
segments and all of the Poes
segments and we check to see if there is
any intersection between any of
these in theory it's possible to have a
polygon inside another so their edges
their segments don't intersect but we
are not going to have that situation
because of the sizes that we have
defined and um topology of the network
so let's return true here and return
false here now let's go back here and
before I refresh I'm going to save this
state so that when I refresh I'm going
to have this same situation and let's
refresh now and see what
happens so this one Building from here
disappeared it's okay if we have empty
spaces like this sometimes we're going
to fill them with trees you'll
see now let's test a little
bit oh oh there is some weird fidgeting
happening there on that
side let me try to isolate when it
happens like this one there should
definitely be a building there I'm going
to save this state and try to fix it the
problem is is actually inside of
our get intersection function here and
it's not really a problem of the logic
or the math but it has to do with
floating Point
numbers sometimes this bottom here is
basically zero but because of how
floating Point numbers work it's not
exactly zero it's very very close to it
and that's the situation
that you see here the building
disappears here because that triggers
that bottom to be close to zero instead
of zero so some kind of fake
intersection appears there and I'm going
to fix this by just using here a small
Epsilon value and instead of saying here
bottom different than zero I'm going to
say absolute value of the bottom because
it can be either way is is greater than
Epsilon and let's refresh and see what
happens
here and the problem is gone and you
will see that there is no more fidgeting
happening now let's move on and generate
trees in this
region I'm going to close some of these
tabs I have open here at the top and go
back to The Constructor here in World JS
and prepare a holder for these
trees and they will be generated
here
generate
trees in a new private
method generate
trees and let's start by giving this uh
parameter and say we want to generate 10
trees somewhere in the region occupied
by our graph now the way this will work
is it's going to prepare a trees array
here and while the length of this array
is less than the count it's going to try
to add more trees here and for now they
will be just simple
points and I will randomize the location
using lurp so I'm going to lurp between
the left side of the region the right
side of the region and then from the top
to the bottom and these Left Right top
bottom we will need to Define
above but basically randomly generating
trees within the region is what we're
doing here and let's push the tree into
this dis array and return trees like so
now for this Left Right top and bottom
top is going to be this point right here
it's the minimum y value of the
buildings and these um envelopes
sometimes the envelope could be the
topmost thing like
maybe and this situation right here and
same goes for the bottom so we need all
the points coming from the envelopes
forming the road and the polygons
forming the buildings for the road I'm
actually going to use the segments from
the road borders that we have
already so here let's take those points
into a
variable points is equal to and here I'm
going to form an array with from the
road
borders let's map each segment so that
P1 and P2 go in a new array and after
all of them are here in an array so an
array of pairs of points also arrays we
can flatten that into one single array
of points
and we do a similar thing also for the
buildings but here we
map the points because they are
available as uh part of the Poley and we
flatten these as well otherwise we're
going to have a big array of small
arrays with four
elements okay and now we get left right
top and bottom so left is going to be
the minimum
value we map again from these points so
that we only take the x value and we
spread here the spread is used just to
take individual items not the whole
array and we've used it everywhere here
and um let's do the same thing for the
right but with the maximum
here and let's copy both of
these for the
top with the Y value here and the
bottom with the Y value here so minan
max min max is uh okay here and let's
draw these trees so similar how we do
the buildings here I'm going
to Loop and say that
through all the trees draw the tree they
are points for now now let's
refresh and you can see something funny
happening here they're generating again
and again and again and again at each
frame
because here in index
HTML we do generate on each frame and
because we use Randomness we get this
funny effect going on but it's kind of
okay because it does show us that the
region where they're appearing is indeed
what we expect it's probably time to
stop generating this graph again and
again on each frame it's very processor
intensive and only generated if it
changes for that we're going to go here
and calculate the hash for the graph a
kind of unique
identifier so let's say that the old
graph hash is the
graph hash we're going to implement this
function soon and this is going to be
the one when the page loads in the
beginning and here before generate we
are going to check if the graph hash is
different than the old graph
hash then we generate and all the graph
hash gets updated to the graph hash like
so let's close this and invent this
better and the hash I'm just going to
stringify the graph so in graph JS
here at the top I'm going to add the
hash function that only converts this
into a
string let's
refresh and you can see now the points
is dark points here are now the trees
and every time we change the graph they
actually get
regenerated so what we did
works next will be avoid generating
trees in these illegal places like on
the road here or inside of this
building let's go to world
JS where we generate the trees
and above this Loop I'm going to have a
holder for these illegal poys where we
don't want things to be inside
so illegal
poce a new array and here I'm going to
spread the buildings they are Poes still
at this stage later we're going to
actually make a building class for each
of them so we'll have to refactor this
code a little bit but now this works
just fine and from the envelopes I'm
going to take each individual po like
this so let's check to see if the points
that we are adding here should be kept
as a tree or not and I'm going to
implement this like so keep is true by
default and then looping through the
illegal Poes
if this
poly contains the
point
P then we say we don't keep it keep is
false and we can also break here because
it's enough that the tree is in one poly
it's not going to be inside another one
as well so no point to look for another
one in this case and here here I'm going
to wrap this
in his keep then push the tree to the
trees otherwise this is going to try
again and again until you reach that
count let's save and
refresh and now the trees don't
intersect those and we could try also
changing the graph a little bit just to
see multiple Generations and it doesn't
seem like any intersection is happening
so the trees are
in almost okay places the problem is
these trees also have a size right so
maybe this is too small of a space for
the tree to be in and that's what we are
going to need to do next let's define
the size for these trees here as
another
parameter and I'm going to save it here
as a
attribute and when drawing the trees
let's also give them
this size so that
we see them properly and I'm going to
give them a color that is transparent
black so that we see intersections
between trees as well that's another
thing that we're going to look out for
close this save and
refresh and now you see those things
that I was talking about so these trees
first of all they intersect and then
also they hit the other objects there so
we need to take care of these
somehow let's first take care of these
trees that intersect so if a tree is too
close to another tree then we just don't
generate it there we try to generate it
again so back in the generate Tre
function here just before we decide if
we keep the point or not I'm going to
say if we have kept it so far we are
going to Loop through all of the
trees and if the distance from the
tree to this point that we want to
decide on is less than the size of the
tree then we don't keep
it we can also break save and
refresh and now the trees shouldn't
intersect each other anymore because we
said that the distance between the trees
should be bigger than a tree so that
problem is solved but let's also solve
the problem of being too close to the
road or too close to the building
Poes so here where we check if the
illegal poies contain the point I'm also
going to check
or the
distance from the poly to the point is
less than half the tree size so here we
just need the radius let's save and
implement this distance to point
function inside of the
polygon maybe
here distance to
point for a
polygon is going to return the minimum
distance between the point point and all
its
segments so I'm just going to map
through all the segments and return the
distance to the point from that segment
and then spread and return the minimum
of that let's save and now we have to
implement the distance from a point to
the segment so we go to the segment
file maybe somewhere
here and I'm going to paste some code
this code is explained in my other video
and I'm not going to go through it now
you can also copy this code from a link
in the description and notice one thing
that the distance to point uses this
project Point function here so that's
why there are two methods that I pasted
here and also one more Vector operation
the dot product needs to be add added in
utils so save this file and then in
utils where our Vector operations
are maybe somewhere
here I'm going to paste this dot product
now let's save and
refresh and you can see where the trees
are now this is a time when you should
be a little bit careful because well if
your space is so
small that the trees wouldn't be
possible to fit you're going to get an
error and not really an error but a
problem with the execution your while
here will never end because trees's
length will never reach count
so that's why I've used only a few trees
until now we would like to write this in
a way that it doesn't depend on a count
but on something else because if I'm
going to make now a very big graph here
like so it's still going to generate 10
trees but much of this space is going to
be empty 10 trees in a very very big
city will be will be nothing so the way
we will rewrite this is not having a
counter here but having a try count here
so what we will do is we will try to add
trees and if at some point we tried a
lot we just assume there are enough
trees we can't add
anymore so what we do here is try count
set it to zero and here let's
say while we try for 100 100
times we're going to do all of this if
we manage to find the space for a tree
then we reset the try
count and then increase the try count on
each step this is very important
otherwise we have an infinite loop again
now refresh the
page and you can see the trees and they
are 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10 11 12 13 14
but the number of trees will really
depend on the size of the area here
really and uh come to think about it
there are some
situations like I don't really care what
is here in this section it's so far away
from the road if I think about our
self-driving scenario we will mostly
just watch what happens on the road and
we might see some trees here here maybe
here if we zoom out a bit but our Focus
will be on the road so generating trees
so far away is kind of a waste of
memory and I'm going to add a control
for that so let's go here and add
another filtering
step if we still keep the tree up to
this point we are going to check if it's
close to something
by default we say that is false and then
Loop through all of the illegal polies
again and if the distance from the
poly to the
point is less than I'm going to put here
tree size * 2 so that I can fit up to
two trees uh away from the from the
items then I say yes there is something
nearby we are closed to something and we
can break we don't need to look further
and here I'm going to say keep is this
close to
something now save
refresh and you can see now the trees no
longer get generated in these sections
now this piece of code with all this
filtering is a little bit long it's
quite long actually maybe should
refactor it somehow extract these as
functions but I'm just going to add here
some comments so this is going to be a
check if the tree is inside or nearby
the
building or the
road and then here
check if
Trees Too
Close to other
trees and
here avoiding trees in the middle of
nowhere so I think this is fine let's
save refresh and test
again
sometimes these buildings can still be
quite close to each other and I don't
like that very much that uh spacing is
not preserved also here between these
ones because there's this point here on
this otherwise straight line let me save
this state so that I have it for f
future testing and go where we generate
the
buildings here we check to see if it
intersects the poly but we can also pass
now if the bases of I distance to
poly base of
J is less than this spacing that's also
a problem and we need this distance to
poly function implemented in polygon JS
but it's going to be quite easy we
just go
through all the
points
and say that for each point we take out
the distance to that
poy so now the distance between two Poes
is actually the distance between the
closest points it's not exactly what we
want because sometimes you might have
poies that are offset a little bit and
then the distance will appear to be this
um even though they are touching but it
doesn't matter very much in our case
because of how aligned the things are
and for this we would need to have a way
to calculate distance between two
segments and I don't have a tutorial for
that yet so it's just going to have to
do let's save and
refresh and now you can see here that
building is gone it's going to leave an
empty space there but it's just fine
maybe it's going to get filled by some
tree like now there will be trees
there let's
test
uhuh there's also one more problem here
these buildings are now leaving gaps
here again and this is because of that
floating Point Number issue sometimes
the buildings that are like this and
should have a spacing there don't have
it because when we calculate the
distance now because of the floating
Point values just appear a little bit
short so back here in World JS instead
of just spacing I'm going to add a small
Epsilon here as
well
so
minus the Epsilon save let's save this
state and
refresh and now you can see that those
buildings don't have the Gap
there what if you want things to look 3D
well you could refactor this entire app
to use a 3D rendering engine some people
already ported the code in Phase One to
use 3js or even used other programming
languages to do it so what I'm going to
teach you now is not the only way to do
it and I'm not really sure I recommend
it I mean if you really want to make
something three the user Library it will
take care of cameras lights and a bunch
of other things making the end result
more professional but I think teaching
you this is still interesting because I
like the way it looks and getting this
to work was actually easier than I
thought you may also find the math
interesting since it touches on some
principles of how 3D renderers work even
though they mostly use triangles or
boxal and we won't be doing any of
that I promise I'll stop here and we
won't go to higher dimensional
spaces get it no because I have that
video on how to calculate distances
between points in higher dimensions and
no no no let's start converting our
tree points here into actual trees so
instead of pushing just P here we're
going to push a new tree at be with this
given tree
size let's go to index HTML and import a
tree object and I'm going to copy here
this viewport and the trees will be
inside of
items slash tree the buildings will be
also in items so let's go inside of JS
and
create the items
folder and then inside the items we are
going to have
our
threejs and this is going to be just a
simple class again with a
Constructor at the given center with the
given size let's also store these
attributes
Center and the size
and by the size I mean the size of the
base of the tree
so let's make it the
year and the draw method for now is just
going
to draw a point at the
center with the given size and let's
make it green this time so that we know
when we test if it if it works or if
we're testing some wrong version now
this code won't work directly we need to
refactor a little bit here in World JS
you see here where we are checking to
see if we're too close to other trees
distance between tree and point makes no
sense so we need to take here instead of
tree we add tree do Center and also when
drawing here at the bottom everything we
don't need to pass these styles to the
tree anymore because the tree knows to
draw itself so let's save this and
refresh and now the circles here are
green I'm going to teach you how to make
them look 3D is next let's begin by
drawing a line at an offset a segment at
an offset here so inside of tree JS we
are going
to
calculate the top of the
tree as the center but adding an offset
so it's going to be to the top left
towards the top left this offset by 40
on X and 4 and Y and now let's draw a
segment from Center to
top like this save
refresh and you can see this it kind of
looks like
sticks going up from this circle but we
are watching all of them from the same
angle and we don't really want that we
want the angle to change depending on
our Viewpoint here so these should look
like that but these should go the other
direction so we need to know this
direction from the Viewpoint to the
center of the tree we're going to
implement our 3d effect based on this
simple fact if the Viewpoint is above
the item the top and the bottom align
perfectly but if they're not there's a
bigger offset here than here let's go
back here and do just that I'm going to
calculate here this
difference as the difference between the
center and
the a
Viewpoint now this Viewpoint is
something we need access to and I'm
going to pass it here like this so the
world needs to give it to the tree
somehow and the world has to get it from
somewhere so it's going to be past here
and in index
HTML in animate where we're doing the
drawing this is where we calculate the
Viewpoint and we get it from the offset
of the viewport but it's actually the
opposite of the offset at the view part
so we
do this Viewpoint is scaling the
viewport offset by minus one and we pass
it
here to the world like
that save
refresh and um it doesn't work I think
we forgot here to pass this
diff here instead of our outc coded
value there
refresh and now we get something more
like it it looks like these trees are
really really tall things
here maybe too much basically if we
focus on this one tree here it's now
this distance from the center and it's
going to have this length the same
distance as that so it's way too much
maybe we can go with half or or even
less so I'm going to go here inside of
3js and this difference I'm going to
scale it I will type here scale the
difference by
0.5 save
refresh and now this effect is not so
pronounced
anymore so I think it can be even a
little bit less and we can take this out
and call it
maybe height
coefficient and this is going to be here
a
parameter and it will control the height
pretty much let's set it to
0.3 and here height coefficient
equals the height coefficient so that
the tree knows how tall it is safe and
refresh this looks about
right now we're going to start styling
these trees and we're going to form them
from many levels stacked on top of each
other we're going to go
here and let's define our
level count how many levels we want the
trees to have I'm going to put seven and
um let's loop from Level
zero to level
count level
Plus+ and get a t value that we will use
in
interpolation so this is going to be
between zero and one maybe should take
special consideration here when dividing
by zero if level count is one but I
don't bother with that
now and then the point that we will use
at each of these levels is going to come
from linear interpolation between the
center and the top that we calculated
previously using this T
value and now we we can just say
Point
draw in the same way that we did the
center and actually we don't need to
draw the center anymore because it's
already taken care of at level zero
that's the bottommost circle now so
let's implement this lurp 2D function
it's actually not here yet in utils we
have lurp but this slurp to the is
just lurp applied on the X and Y
components of the two
points
so like
this save
refresh and now we
see kind of like a
cylinder there made of seven different
circles on top of each other let's give
them a different color so that they come
brighter towards the top and we go back
here in tree JS I don't think we need
this segment here anymore instead we go
here and say the color is equal to and
we're going to interpolate again using
the simple lurp this time for just the
green green value in this color so we're
going to go between 50 and 200 these are
just values that I like how they how
they
look and I added some values for red and
for blue as well they are quite low
values so they just control the shade a
little bit and now this color we can
actually just pass it here like so save
refresh and now this cylinder looks like
that next step we also interpolate the
size so it becomes smaller towards the
top and um we do that
here size lurp between this size and 40
I just chose as a value that looks good
to me but you can play with these values
if you want now let's pass this
size here I I think this should work
save
refresh and now the trees look like
that they start to resemble
something like what trees are supposed
to look like at least these kind of uh
Christmas trees let's make them look a
little bit more fuzzy so this is too
abstract for my taste and we're going to
instead of drawing perfect circles here
we're going to draw some kind of noisy
circles uh you'll
see basically here instead of using
points to define the levels we remove
that and let's use Poes instead
and I'm going to make a private method
generate level one level from the point
and with the given size and let's say
poly. draw at
CTX let me give here the color and I
don't want to use any stroke style for
the tree so I'm putting here one with
Alpha zero and now we can go up here and
implement the
generate level
method where we just draw circle like
shape around this point with
this size so now let
me take points here that we will put on
the circle shape and the radius will be
half of the
size and now I'm going to loop with this
a variable for angle starting at zero
and going all the way to 360° or 2 pi
radians and I will increase a by Pi ided
by 16 so this means we will have 32
points along the circle and here we need
to not use just a fixed radius otherwise
it's going to be a circle but we will
get a noisy radius where we just
multiply the
radius by math dot random like this and
then we push to the points a point where
we translate our original point at the
given
angle with the
noisy
radius like so and let's return here a
new
polygon with these points now save and
refresh and uh you will see some funny
stuff happening here maybe if we type
debugger in the cons so we get a better
idea of how these trees look like
because the radius now is between zero
and the tree size you get these spiky
spiky look to the
trees I guess it could be okay but I
don't like it that much instead what
we're going to do is add a lurp here
between 0.5 and one so that we just get
the upper half of random pretty much so
between 0.5 and one are the random
values if we
do this save and
refresh and now this looks more like
what I want but of course they shouldn't
be fidgeting like this
and this is an annoying situation here
because many programming languages do
have a way to Generate random numbers
with a fixed seed and you could do that
fairly easy
but not in JavaScript so I had to come
up with something that generates kind of
random numbers but always the same thing
for each tree so that when redrawing it
doesn't re generate the tree like
that and I have a quick fix here for
that so my kind
of random number that I will generate
comes from this very
simple
mathematical
formula
okay and now we pass it
here instead of this actual
random save
refresh and now the trees don't shake
like that anymore so this formula
is um I'm not going to go too deep into
it but cosine gives you a value between
minus one and one square the cosine is
going to give you a value between 0 and
one so same as the random that we had
previously and inside of this
cosine I mixed together the
angle with the center of the tree and
with the sze and what this means is that
each level of the tree is going to look
a little bit different because the size
contributes to it each part of the level
according to the angle is going to look
different because a contributes to it
and I'm also offsetting a by this Center
X location of the tree so that two trees
don't look the same if you remove for
example this part here all of the trees
will look the same if I remember right
let's save and
refresh so you can see all of them have
here this Spike Spike Spike spike
because the center location doesn't
affect in any way and same goes for
other values I also have some hack here
with remainder when dividing by 17
because it's a prime number and also it
adds a little bit of fuzziness to the
result but still if you save and refresh
you will see that there is some kind of
pattern to how these trees are being
generated they are not exactly the same
but they do have some similarities like
maybe two of these thicker branches here
and here and here and all of them kind
of seem to have that you can find some
pattern there these are not really
random numbers they are just random Mish
numbers and they are influenced a lot by
how the cosign looks like so that's why
you get this periodic change there
anyway it's just a function I mushed
there together to get this to work
alternatively you could also save these
levels when you generate the tree and
then just draw it but I didn't want to
bother with that it would have been more
work explaining
things now one thing that we could have
here in the Constructor is also defining
the base of the tree so I'm just going
to call here generate level at the
center and with the size this is already
happening here when level is zero but
now I'm storing that as the base of the
tree and this is
important because this base of the tree
is something that the car
May interact with like if it hits this
base of the tree then it hits the tree
pretty much so the base is giving us
segments here on the side of the tree on
the bottommost level that we could
use now I'm going to remove this it's
just for debugging so you see what the
base was and we're going to continue to
generate the buildings next so let's
close this tree and the details and in
World
JS here this is the end of the generate
buildings method instead of just having
the bases of the buildings those
polygons we are going to map
these to new
buildings as well and we're going to do
very similar things for the buildings
starting with let's fix the situations
where buildings were poly
previously so in the
generate trees method here we are using
the buildings as Poes we are accessing
here the points directly but the
building will also have a base like we
added for the trees just now and that's
how we will get the points from now on
and also here illegal poies it's not
just getting the buildings those are
going to be new objects so what we do
here is take out just the base from
these buildings and now we have the Poes
here to work with in the draw method
below we also have to pass this
Viewpoint to the buildings they'll also
have a 3D look and let's go to index
HTML
and include the building similarly as we
include the tree
here building JS inside of items here
where the tree
is
building JS and let's define the
building class
so simple class with the
Constructor getting a poly for the base
and a height
coefficient let's set it 0.4 a little
bit taller than the trees just to see
how it looks like and now let's store
this base
here and the height
coefficient and uh write a simple draw
method CTX and the
Viewpoint and
draw the
base and the context and let's make it
white and uh grayish light gray stroke
so let's just debug to see if our
refactoring caused any issues save and
refresh and now the buildings are white
but no 3d effect just
yet for that I'm going to go here at the
top and calculate the top points on the
ceiling of the
building
so top
points is taking the base
points and remapping each point to
something else and here we type add this
point scale
subtract p
Viewpoint this height
coefficient like so and the ceiling is
going to be a new
polygon from these top points this
formula here is the same that we used
here in 3js but it's divided so we have
first add scale SC and then this diff is
subtract of that
so add scale
subtract it's the same thing now let's
draw the ceiling as well I'm going to do
the same thing as with the base but the
ceiling save and
refresh and now you can see that
floating ceiling there over the
buildings
over the building base let's do the
sides as
well I'm going to go here after we have
the
ceiling and the
sides are going to be polygons as well
and we will make these sides by
connecting two points two consecutive
points from the base with two
consecutive points from the ceiling but
in reverse order in the ceiling you'll
see
so we do
this looping through all the
points like that and let me just write
here next I for I + one basically but
also make it loop around so I'm going to
take the reminder when
considering the length of this array so
the last point is going to have next the
first point in this polygon of the base
and now let's generate these sides one
by one inside of this for Loop so it's
going to be a
poly new
polygon like this and first
point base points of IE and then base
points of next
eye and then the ceiling points but
they're already in that top points and
it's shorter to right so top
points next eye and top
points I so basically bottom and then
top reverse and let's add this poly to
the
sides and now before drawing the ceiling
we're going to go here and draw all the
sides one by one let me just copy this
here and this is side I'll use the same
style save and
refresh and
um some things look really good like
this but some of them look like these I
don't know empty boxes here and some are
even over the other ones it's um a
little bit confusing what is going on
but uh the thing is this side here it's
being drawn and after that this side
here it's being drawn so you see this
line from this side on the right on top
of this side that should actually block
that side on the
right this means that we need to draw
these sides in a way that makes sense
the backmost ones first and then the
front ones second so we will sort the
sides of this building so that the
further away ones are going to be in the
beginning they get drawn first and then
the closest ones to this Viewpoint are
going to be second
we do that
here calling
sort and the call back function will be
this one uh comparison function that
takes a and b to polygons this time and
we write the result to be distance to
point to the
Viewpoint minus a distance to
point
Viewpoint so we're sorting all of the
sides all of the polygons according to
the distance to the viewpoint but
because we write it in this way with B
uh first and a second it means that we
sort in reverse order so the closest
ones are going to be the last ones to
draw let's save and
refresh and now you don't see that
problem that kind of
empty box look anymore but we still have
some problems like this building being
drawn before this
building the same logic goes here for
the buildings as well but we're going to
use the base poy to decide which
building to draw first and actually
trees as well so here the tree goes
underneath the building so we need to
group trees and buildings together and
do this
sorting via their
base at the same time to get the 3d
effect to work so I'm going to go back
to World JS here and let's combine these
items into one array I'm going to write
here
items
buildings and
trees and let's pass here
items and this is
item
item we don't need the second Loop
anymore because we're now drawing them
with the single Loop let's just see if
this works it should be so that now the
trees are over the buildings because
they are drawn later save
refresh so yeah same problems as before
but now trees are over the build
buildings so let's do that sorting now
for these items here and it's the same
thing
really sorting the items same kind of
function but now we tell the
Poes the base of these objects to
calculate the distance to the
point save and the refresh
and now this looks
proper you can see this tree here
between this building and this other
building quite nicely and it changed
relationship now so now
it's drawn before this
building now it's drawn after this
building so this works just fine you can
see sometimes these uh weird lines here
but these are actually from the graph
editor um it's not any glitch or
anything like that they won't appear
when we just use the world without the
editor
showing now you can style these however
you want you can go further and make
them look even nicer I will have a
special video for channel members and
they will get to see how I made them
have roofs and also how to make a more
realistic 3d effect because this one if
you pay attention what happens here
these buildings just get taller and
taller like that and if your viewport is
bigger and bigger they will just look
really crazy so something is not right
here you shouldn't exceed a size when
looking at the building like this and
the building should have a proper height
not a height coefficient what whatever
that meets so I will have a special
video for that it's not going to be very
long so not too much content in it but
uh the code from that I will put now and
mix it together with this one and you
can look at it afterwards and selfstudy
it even if you don't watch that video
the worlds we can create now are much
more complicated than that straight line
we had in phase one but adding some
traffic rules here will really give us a
lot of flexibility in phase three we'll
be able to teach the car all kinds of
things because our world is really 2D
apart from these tricks here we will
enforce these rules as markings on the
road I'll show you a clever way of
adding the markings so they snap to the
road and always have the correct
orientation we're not going to have our
users worry about things like that they
should work as little as possible to get
something nice try remember that as the
general rule we're going to start adding
markings to the world and we'll begin
with stop markings but to do this we're
going to need another editor um a stop
editor and a way to change from the
graph editing mode to the stop editing
mode I'm going to do that here by adding
two buttons for that they're going to be
mutually
exclusive let's start by adding an empty
space to separate from the save and load
functionalities and the first button
it's going to have an ID this time
because we're going to change the way it
looks soon in
JavaScript and uh we need to access it
and when we click we're going to set the
mode to the graph so this will enable
the graph editing
tools and the second button is going to
have an ID stop BTN and onclick it's
going to set the mode to
stop let me close this tag and I'm going
to style these buttons using emojis
again for the graph and one for the Stop
like this let's save and
refresh the buttons are here but uh
let's style the buttons a bit better
they have this default view and I don't
really like it let's make them bigger at
least in
Styles I'm going to add a style for the
buttons let's put the background color
white for maximum contrast and the font
size 20
pixels
refresh and they're bigger but I would
like them to look Square as well and I
found that adding here a padding of
5775 does the trick
refresh and it's fine but this border
here that the button has is a little bit
uh nerdy and I will remove it and also
add rounded Corners as well so here
border set to none and Border
radius
five and
refresh looks much better now this
button and maybe this one too the
contrast is not so good it's not so easy
for me to see this button I'm going to
add also a drop shadow on the bottom
right so let's have a text Shadow one
one
black and I like buttons to have this uh
hand cursor when you're hovering them so
let me add all also here this
cursor pointer save and
refresh and now this looks good and
feels good I think but pressing them
does nothing this set mode is not
defined yet so let's define it I'm going
to go in index HTML here at the bottom
and say set
mode and the first thing that it will do
is is
disable any editor all the editors
disable everything and then we're going
to have a switch case that will enable
the one with the given mode but let's
handle first this disable editors and
only visually so make the buttons look
disabled if they are disabled and I'm
going to start with the graph button and
give it a gray background color and I'm
also going to remove the colors in the
Emojis by passing a
grayscale
filter with the 100% like this and this
we have to do also for the Stop button
so stop
button and stop button now if we save
and refresh press one of these buttons
no more error there and both them are
disabled now because this set mode was
called so after they're disabled let's
enable the one that has been clicked
depending on this mode so switch
depending on the mode if it was the
graph I'm going to set the background
color of the graph button back to
White and
remove the filter
as well and let's break now I will copy
this also for the
stop using the stop
button stop button save and refresh and
clicking on them now
toggles the behavior but when we refresh
the page one of them should be selected
and I'm going to enable this
graph by default so I will go above here
where we before we start the animation
Loop and I will type set
mode graph and now we can start talking
about the functionality as well not just
the look and feel so what we want to
happen here in set mode is
to enable the graph editor if we Press
On the graph button and let's add this
functionality to our graph editor it
doesn't have it
yet enable and here disable editors it's
also going to need a way to disable
it let's save and go inside
our graph editor and the first thing
we'll do is remove this call to adding
event listeners because we want that to
happen in the enable method so
enable we add event
listeners like this and then the disa is
going to
remove event
listeners like
that remove event listeners should look
very much like ad event listeners but
with
remove in all of
these parts so
remove like this let's save and
refresh and now we are able to edit the
graph here to create a graph and when we
switch to the stop editing mode which
doesn't yet exist but it should disable
the graph
editor we still can edit the
graph the problem is here when we add
event listeners and we call bind on
this method it creates a new method
where this inside of it is
this so remove event listener expects to
get the exact same thing here when
removing it not to create a new copy of
handle Mouse down with this bound into
it this is a problem and we're going to
need to fix it and the best way I know
how is just to store this version of the
function here as an attribute and then
use the
attribute here and here so hopefully you
get the point I'm going to store here
the bound Mouse
down function and let's just copy this
from
here and now put
this
here and
here the second one is going to
be bound Mouse
move and we're going to cut this from
here and copy
this
here and
here and we have to do something for
these as well because they're Anonymous
functions so actually here we create a
function and here it's another function
they just do the same thing but it's not
the same function that we want to remove
here as well
so let's do the mouse up is
next
Mouse up is um I have it here the last
one let's actually rearrange these
because I think it's more logical to
have the order like this with the mouse
Events first and then this context menu
at the end and let me cut
this here and now we pass this here and
here
here and finally context
menu context menu I think could be also
removed forever we never really need the
context menu in this application but uh
I'm not going to bother with that now I
just keep this consistent and make sure
that all the listeners are added and
removed like
this now
save refresh try to add the
graph change to this
stop try to add more
points and it doesn't work we can't
select points we can't do anything with
the graph anymore now but if we reenable
it we can and disabling it
again has this weird artifact now
because we still have a select point
there so I'm going to go here where the
disable is and let's pass also selected
is
false and hovered is
false save
refresh and let's
try one more
time when pressing this that line
disappeared so no more problem and we
can can actually Define a new graph here
to use because it's time to implement
the stop marking as
well and we should add stops on
something I'm going to keep this format
now let's save it so when we refresh it
loads this graph now and we can begin to
implement the stop editor we're going to
go in index
HTML and um
it's going to work pretty much like this
graph editor Let me just copy this
instantiation here and say stop editor
is a new stop
editor but adding the stop markings on
the road is going to need some
information about the road itself not
just that graph so how big the road is
and something like that so we're going
to pass here instead of graph world for
this one
otherwise um here when we do the display
for the graph editor we're also going to
have a display for our stop
editor dispose I'm not going to deal
with this now we will handle it a little
bit later but then here this enable
needs to happen here for the stop as
well and the disable here
let's implement the stop editor in a
separate file and we will have more
editors now so I'm going to move graph
editor and the stop editor into a new
folder let's call this
editors and I'm going to move this
editors here above the items so that
these files that are directly in
JavaScript are grouped together and
let's copy this graph editor with
a stop
editor and create now the new folder
injs called
editors move graph editor inside it and
create the new file stop
editor JS next to it now this
functionality will be quite similar to
the graph
editor so we will be copying some things
from there but let's first handle this
Constructor passing the viewport and the
world which is a little bit different
and store the
viewport and the world as object
attributes
and also add here a reference to the
viewport canvas and and a reference to
the
context stop editor will also have a
display method and these items will come
in handy for that now let's go to graph
editor and I'm going to copy enable
disable and adding removing the event
listeners I think they are pretty much
the
same like this but but um this selected
and hovered will make no sense here and
we actually won't have a mouse up event
listener this editor is going to be
simpler than the graph editor so Mouse
up won't be needed and we won't be
dragging
anything and let's begin to implement
this mouse move private method here
handle Mouse move I'm going to copy it
from graph
editor here and to begin with I want to
win hovering the mouse over some of
these segments to highlight that segment
the thing is these stops will be added
on the roads themselves so we're going
to use them as guides otherwise it's
going to be very difficult to place that
stop exactly at the location and the end
result won't look good so we're going to
use the segments that exist already as
some kind of guides and our interface
for using this stop editor is going to
be much easier to use much more user
friendly so we begin by finding what is
the nearest segment where we want to add
this stop
on so this get nearest point is going to
change to a get nearest
segment and we're going to store that
segment in a
constant get
nearest
segment and here let me align these a
little bit better they go out of the
screen and it's going to use the graph
segments but here we don't have this
graph directly we have the world so the
graph is part of this
world
graph segments like this and this
dragging part we don't need
it what we do need to do is check if we
do get a segment if there is a nearest
segment under this threshold and if
there is I'm going to Define
find an attribute called intent again I
want to show where the marking would
appear if we would click the
button so the intent for now is going to
be the segment itself otherwise it's
going to be
null like this and let's take out Mouse
and intent as attributes up here as
well
now to see this intent we need to
implement the display method as
well if there is an
intent I'm just going to draw it on the
context with
default
styling and we still need to implement
this yet nearest segment function it's
going to be in math utils at the top
next to the first function we
implemented in this file which was get
nearest point and now we're also going
to have get
nearest
segment which takes the location and a
list of
segments same threshold and here we Loop
through each segment of
segments and when we calculate the
distance we can't use this Pythagorean
theorem implementation to get the
hypotenuse we have to call from the
segment the distance to point instead
and here the nearest will not be a point
it's going to be the segment that has
been found with the smaller distance
again and again eventually leading to
the one with the smallest distance
now if we save and
refresh we get an error here in the stop
editor because it doesn't have yet a
handle Mouse down method
so let's just add an empty one here for
now we will handle it
later save and refresh and switch to the
stop
editor and now you can see that segment
being highlighted the nearest segment to
our Mouse location it's not a strong
highlight but there is a
highlight so I want the stop to be
generated at the location centered
exactly on that segment so next thing
we'll do is Project our Mouse location
on that nearest segment if there is a
nearest segment here to get one point
the center of the stop marking for that
will go here when we have the segment
available and I'm just going to
project the point on the
segment by doing this and the projection
may also fall outside of the segment so
that would be a weird uh error there and
I'm going to check here if the offset is
really between zero and one so if the
projected Point Falls indeed on the
segment not on the support line and in
this case the intent is going to become
the projected Point otherwise it's going
to be null
again save refresh switch to the stop
editor and now we get a point there and
we don't have to worry about is the
mouse exactly there or not it's always
going to be perfectly centered just as
we want
it and now it's time to define the
marking itself so it's going to be a
polygon but I'm going to have a
specialized object for it a stop object
for storing and drawing the stop
marking so here we're going to need to
pass
some properties to that the first one is
going to be
the point itself so as before but I want
the marking to orient nicely according
to the segment that it's on so I'm also
going to pass here the direction Vector
of this segment and then a width and
height I want the width to span the
whole Road really and the height let's
just use a factor of that like half the
road width at least for now
now to Define this stop marking we go to
index
HTML and we're going to do that in uh
folder called markings so let me just
copy maybe viewport here and say
markings stop let's close some of these
folders here and create a new one in
JS
markings
and in it our
file stop JS like this the stop class is
also going to be quite simple but the
Constructor has four parameters now so
it's the center location the direction
Vector the width and the
height of this
polygon let's store these as attributes
and then generate that
polygon
somehow so the direction Vector is
already
normalized which is
nice and height and now first thing for
that polygon I'm going to get a support
and it's going to be on the segment and
and height half of the height towards
the front of the segment and half of the
height towards the back of the segment
so we are going to Define this support
as a new segment relative to this center
location by translating Center at the
angle of this direction
Vector half the
height and the second point
is going to be the same but at a
different angle the opposite angle you
can either add um Pi here or say that
you want to
translate opposite way with the minus
here let's debug and implement the draw
method for this stop where we just draw
this um support for
now save refresh change to the stop
editor and hard to see but it's there
this support Vector with half the road
width as its
height let's convert it into a polygon
and to do that I'm going to really use
the envelope trick again so we Define a
new envelope with this
support vector and the width parameter
and no roundness I don't need any
roundness here and just take the poly
from this envelope
object and we debug Now by drawing this
poly instead save refresh select the
stop
editor and there it
is and I just realized that I don't want
this stop marking to be the whole Road I
want it to be just on half of the road
here for the cars that go this way and
they need to stop in this
intersection so we're going to need to
fix that but this is still useful this
could be another marking like maybe the
crossing it's pretty much exactly what
the crossing should look like but for
the stop marking we need some other
guides not these graph
segments we need something
here in the middle between the borders
of the road and the graph segment so
let's define those new Lane guides the
middle of the lane the right lane and
the left lane so they will be Lane
guides in the stop
editor instead of using these we will
pass
Lane
guides and we have to to go to world JS
and Define
them I will store them here as an
array and Below generate here we're
going to need the function to generate
them it's a private method generate Lane
guides and I'm going to use the same
trick that we used with the generating
buildings with these
envelopes so I will copy this here as
well these envelopes will be
actually half the road WID like this and
now we're going to take the union again
so avoid those intersecting
Parts as before
by considering the poly of every
envelope and just returning these
segments we call this method
here and um same as we did with the
envelopes before let's empty the lane
guides if they exist from a previous
rendering and
then push I'm just going to spread here
the result of generate Lane
guides push can actually push multiple
things if you pass them individually not
as an not as an
array and let's quickly debug that these
look as they should I'm just going to go
here at the end of the draw method and
say looping through all of the lane
guides segments
drawing them in
Red Save and refresh and they look good
and now when we switch to the stop
editor you can see it's centering now on
these um Lane guides but the width
should be smaller so going back to the
stop
editor Road width divided by two save
refresh switch to the stop
editor and now it's good let's remove
these
guides and start styling our stop
marking here I'm going to draw a rotated
text saying stop so for that we need to
do the translate and rotate trick we
first translate to Center X and Center
Y and then rotate by the angle of this
direction
Vector let's begin a
path and I'm going to style the text
by centering the basine and
also horizontally way like this and it's
going to be a white
text and it will
say stop at 0 0 because this translate
is already moving us to where we need to
be and rotate helps us out as well now
let's remember to restore to the
original state without these
translations and rotations save refresh
select the stop editor and you can see
now this stop text appearing there but
it should be rotated so I'm going to
subtract half pi from that and um let's
make it also
bigger here we
subtract
90° and um let's set the font
size to be a fraction of the
height I I think this should look
good save refresh stop
editor yeah let's make it bald as
well refresh stop editor and good and
typically these markings are stretched a
lot when they're displayed under the
road so that when you're driving and
they are stretched like this you
actually see them
normally somehow unstretched while
driving so let's do that as well here
after we rotate I'm going to scale this
not horizontally but vertically by a
factor of two and vertically here means
in the new frame of reference after
rotating so save refresh stop
editor I think we can do even even more
maybe
three refresh
stop
editor and uh for some reason it doesn't
align exactly how I want it I'm going to
give it an
offset
here and now it's
good let's draw also the line on top of
it that's the line that the cars
shouldn't um shouldn't cross so that's
going to be the Border here I will store
it as an attribute because this border
is really important for the cars to know
about so let's put it here at the top
and it's going to be the first segment
of the
poly and now drawing this we don't need
to draw the poly anymore it was there
just for
reference and this one we style I'm
going to give it thickness five and
white like the rest of the marking save
refresh stop
editor oh it's not that segment it
should be the other one so uh segments
of two refresh stop
editor that's how we want it but we want
to add it not just see this intent here
so let's do that next and um we're going
to need to go to the stop editor Mouse
down and start to implement it so if we
are going to press left
click
left
click and if we have an intent
here then
markings
push this intent and I'm going to also
delete this intent set it to null
in case somebody presses multiple times
in the same spot now for this markings
I'm going to do a trick here and say
that this markings comes from the
world markings taking advantage of
references here World markings doesn't
exist yet so we need to go to world at
the top and the world is going
to contain
markings it's going to be an empty array
in the beginning and then in the draw
method after drawing these um envelopes
the gray
F I'm going to draw the
markings like
so save refresh stop editor and now
clicking actually adds the stop there at
the
intersection now saving doesn't work yet
if we save nothing really happens except
for saving the graph structure for the
markings we're going to have to do
something else we're going to implement
saving for the markings and actually for
the whole world a little bit later it
makes sense to group everything together
in one one spot but for now we can test
them by just still using these uh
buttons and and clicking it's not too
much trouble I think we added markings
how about removing them as well maybe on
right
click so let's go back to our stop
editor and here on Mouse
down
if the event button is two so the right
click we are going to look through all
of the
markings one by
one get the
poly of that marking
for ease of use and check to see if we
clicked inside the poly so if we clicked
inside the poly of any marking that
marking will be removed so if poly
contains Point our Mouse
location we
splice at
I one element we remove it and
um now we can just return we don't have
to do IUS minus here because we return
anyways save refresh stop editor add
some
stops and remove some
stops seems to work but one thing that
we should still deal with is um this
thing deleting the graph leaves the
markings there let's clear them as well
so going to index HTML l in our dispose
function I'm also going to say World
markings length is zero and now if we
save refresh stop editor add some
markings
here and then we
remove they all go away one thing that
you probably have
noticed is that markings can exist
without the
graph
or outside of the graph like this I
won't bother with
that they are not tied to the graph in
any way users should just add those
markings after they are happy with the
graph structure and in a way it's kind
of what happens in the real world as
well you may end up with markings in
some strange locations for weird reasons
I tried coming coming to A solution that
is more friendly with this part but it
was way too much trouble to teach it and
um I gave up instead I'm going to show
you how to add some other markings so
let's make Crossings Road Crossings next
and the way we'll do that is pretty much
the same that we did everything up till
now for the Stop we have to do it again
for the crossing and after that we are
going to have a step where I'm going to
teach you about refactoring and see the
similarities between those and remove
the duplicate code you'll
see so here let's copy this stop button
and call it
Crossing button set mode to
Crossing and I will put here an emoji of
this person
walking and now every time this stop
button is used I'm going to look for
that and
enter another entry for the
crossing
crossing BTN Crossing BTN we will have
also a Crossing
editor Crossing editor
enable and then here this
code Crossing
BTN Crossing
BTN
Crossing editor let's look also for this
stop editor it has been also used here
with this display
so Crossing
editor
display and of course here where we
initialize it to uh new Crossing
editor
Crossing
editor and importing the file so I'm
going to copy this stop editor here and
say Crossing
editor and marking stop we will copy it
to
markings
Crossing and in instead of making new
files for crossing and Crossing editor
I'm just going to Copy Stop and stop
editor so let's copy this stop editor
and rename it to
Crossing
editor and let's Copy Stop
JS and rename it to
rossing JS and in Crossing JS let's edit
this real quick so here Crossing now I
won't bother with styling it just yet
instead I will just draw here the poly
without any special Styles and remove
what we had previously for for the stop
so we're done with this Crossing for now
and in Crossing editor we have to rename
this to
Crossing editor and we already know the
things that we need to change to get it
to work
differently here instead of the lane
guides we are going to have to use the
graph segments again because it will
Center in the middle of the road and
here the width should be the full Road
width and the object that we create is
not a stop it's a crossing the one we
just
created let's save refresh
and now we have the button here and they
seem to toggle just fine and when we try
adding a Crossing it looks like this but
adding a
stop still looks polished like what we
had it
previously removing things Works without
actually changing to the other one I
find this as a useful thing because it's
sometimes uh quite often that you want
to add a Crossing very close or instead
of an existing other marking so then you
can just right click even though you
have the crossing editor selected and
remove the Stop and create the crossing
where you want it
so I think this is actually a pro even
though the logic wasn't necessarily
planned like that now let's style these
cross cring in a nice way for that we're
going to get a line that is
perpendicular to this support line that
we had
previously and then style that
perpendicular line in some way so let's
go to Crossing JS
here
and we don't need this poly
anymore we will just get this
perpendicular line
line from this direction
Vector this will also return a vector
perpendicular to that one and the logic
is actually quite similar to this but I
want to avoid using translate and the
angle and show you another
implementation using vectors and teach
you the formula for this perpendicular
Vector as well so you could implement it
the same way but I want to teach you
things so let's have here the line a new
segment and now we add to the center
point and we scale this perpendicular
vector by half the width and then copy
this and scale it by half the width but
with a minus in front in the other
direction so you can see similarities
here very much and then let's draw this
line now let's implement this
perpendicular function it's going to be
in math utils
maybe here next to
translate and it's a really easy given a
point we
just flip it so to
speak by changing these coordinates in
this
way save
refresh select the crossing editor and
now we get this perpendicular line there
all we need to do is style it pretty
much so let's go back to our Crossing JS
and add here some
Styles like so the width is going to be
the height of
this marking if that makes sense let's
save and
refresh select this Crossing editor and
now you see it at its
full
height with the width of the line this
is a very thick line now and next we are
going to make it white and give it a
dashed property like this let's save
refresh select the crossing editor and
now it looks like that when the cars are
driving they will need to make a note of
this border and this border here
so two borders are needed now we have to
record both of them here and I'm going
to put them in an
array like
this let's debug see what we did is
working or not I'm going
to try
to draw here all these
borders save refresh Crossing
editor and they look okay so no need for
this debug
anymore and we are done with this
Crossing as well but look at this
Crossing especially this part right here
and the
stop this part right here they are
pretty much the same and now the stop
editor even worse stop editor is very
much like the crossing
editor the only difference are
these Target segments that we use here
and the type of marking that is
created so let's begin by refactoring
this stop editor and the crossing editor
into um so-called marking editor and
then we inherit from that most of the
same
functionality let's copy this stop
editor like this rename it to
marking
editor and here at the top this will be
marking editor and here where we get
these this nearest segment we just pass
this target
segments the target segments will come
from the Constructor so this marking
editor will be told what segments to
look for and it's going to store them
here in an attribute of this
object and the second thing that we need
to do is add here a method for creating
a marker this should be a Dynamic method
that will be overwritten by the stop
editor and the crossing editor in a
different way so this one needs the
center location of the marker and the
direction and that's it the width and
height are things that those subclasses
that will inherit from this super class
will worry about so I just return here
this Center as a point just to have some
something but this function will be
overwritten to be
overwritten by the sub
classes so with this create marking
function in place we are going to call
it
here this create
marking and it doesn't need these last
two parameters and we are done with this
marking editor now we go to stop editor
and
extend so extends marking
editor like this and instead of doing
anything here in the Constructor we just
say super viewport world and the target
segments will be the world Lane guides
in this
case everything else just goes away
because
after extending marking editor the
functionality is there all we need to do
is overwrite the create
marking
method given
these
properties and I'm going to return a new
stop in this case at the center and
Direction
vector and now we can pass here the row
width divided by two and the road width
divided by two this square shape of the
stop marking and that's it now inside of
the crossing editor we do the exact same
thing we
extend marking editor like this we
remove the contents of the
Constructor super with the viewport P
world and the world graph segments this
time so this is the difference and
remove all this
code implement the create marking
function over write it
actually it is already there it's just
returning Center if we don't do
this and return a new Crossing this time
at the center according to the direction
vector and the full Road width this
time and the road width divided by two
and we're done with this refactoring we
just need to include the marking editor
as well so here in index we should
include it before the other editors so
that inheriting it is possible I'm going
to put it here at the top above graph
editor and say marking editor save
refresh and
now everything still works as before but
the code is much much better and we can
do even better we can refactor the
marking as well so in the same way we
are going to copy stop
here rename this to
marking
marking and the border is something that
is different between all of these
markings so I will not have it there and
the draw method for this marking we are
not supposed to draw these objects just
inherit from them but if we do maybe we
draw this poly here instead
so poly draw and I'm just going to use
default styling remove this it's part of
the stop
drawing and that's it now in stop JS we
can
extend
marking
and here we call Super with all of these
parameters like
so and we don't need any of this except
for the Border
there so not so much code removal as in
the other part but there is some still
and let's do the same for the crossing
here so
extends
marking remove this type
super copy paste semicolon and now we
need to include this marking as well so
in the same way I'm going to include it
on top of
this so markings
marking JS save refresh and add some of
these markings
here works just as before but uh we can
do even more
refactoring here inside of index HTML
you remember all this tedious stuff that
we had to do like the stop editors
checking where it is and adding the next
one next to it in all places and the
stop button these buttons and editors
I'm going to group them in an object
called
tools so tools is going to contain now a
tool for the
graph and this one will have access to
the button and the graph
editor now the same goes for the stop a
button for the Stop is stored here and
the editor for the Stop is stored here
and finally the crossing the button for
the crossing we added here and the
editor for the
crossing we add it here as well and with
this object we can Loop through these
values here so instead of having three
displays here or like so we can
just
Loop through all of the tools like
this then take the tool editor and
display we are not gaining much like
three lines here and three lines here
these go away but when more editors are
going to be added there this will make a
difference and of course the effort of
typing something new here and
remembering that you have to type
something there goes away with this
implementation now we're going to copy
this
again here in disable
editors here we want to disable not
display
but also this code for the button we can
copy it here and just say
tool
button tool button and all this code
goes away and it should be the same
thing now this switch case here becomes
much simpler because these values here
match those from the tools that I
defined on top this was on
purpose and that means we don't need the
switch at all anymore we just remove it
align this
better and this is going to be the
tool from this mode
button style background color style
filter and here we enable not the button
but the editor instead now save the file
refresh the page
and everything still works just fine
there's something a little bit more that
we could do is that
this copying here can also be omitted if
we just pass directly
here the instantiation
of the
object like
so so these are not needed
anymore but uh this graph editor is
actually called here in this
pose so
let's remove this but also edit this
pose here and say tools
graph
editor dis poose save refresh try to add
some
markings and when we press this
pose everything still
works now the next marking we are going
to add is not a kind of marking that you
find on the roads really it's going to
be a start marking where the
self-driving cars are going to spawn at
so we're going to need that in the
future and let's see how quickly we can
Implement that now that we have this
better code structure here we are going
to go at the top where the buttons are
and I'm going to copy this one and say
start
BTN set Mode start and repl this Emoji
here I'm going to use a blue car because
my car is blue and now here in the tools
we are going to have to add a new
entry for
the
start using start
BTN and start
editor we also have to include these two
new files here
so let me copy this stop editor
here call it start
editor and this stop marking
here call
it start and to implement this we just
copy the stop editor from here rename it
to start
editor and the only change we do here is
rename start
editor and this is going to create a new
start and then
here copying the stop
marking as the
start renaming this to start and this
marking will not have any
border instead it's going to have an
image we just display the picture of the
car that I drew in phase one of the
course so let's store here an image New
Image and set its source to
car.png and in draw we don't need this
border we also don't need this
scale but we do go between the
rotation and the restore point here and
here we draw the
image we draw the
image like so and 0 0 would Center it so
that the top left corner of the image is
going to be at this center point so we
need to offset it by half its
width and half its
height I've added an image of a car now
here it's this one so we can save
refresh and now this button is here
toggling seems to work just fine and the
car appears there so here we're telling
the system cars will come at this
location and of course maybe they should
respect some of these markings as well
now I will Implement four more markings
but I will fast forward this
part
this is what I have now there are quite
many uh new things here there is a yield
which is quite similar to stop also a
barking here the target is where cars
are supposed to go and probably the most
complicated one is this traffic light
here which has a little bit of logic of
how to change the colors
um I will make a special video for the
channel members showing the full process
but uh otherwise you can take the code
after this lesson and inspect it
yourself it's not rocket science but uh
the code structure could be a little bit
better for the logic of these lights I
just didn't bother with it because I'm
not even sure if we will use them in
phase three it depends how good our
neural network works so
let's
see so far we've been saving the grass
in local storage and regenerating
everything based on that when the page
loads but in this way we lose the
markings also we can't save multiple
worlds like this and the trees appear
randomly and maybe you don't want that
not to mention that the worlds can be
quite big and generating them when the
page loads can be time consuming you'll
see when we work with real world data
I'm not patient enough to draw such a
large graph now so I think that having a
way to store the information in actual
World files and loading them afterwards
is a must you'll see it really Saves the
Day done now you have a nice world like
this and you want to store it save it
somehow with everything all the markings
everything we'll do that using local
storage as well so we're going to store
here as the world
item
stringify the
world it's now here if we
type get
item world all the information is here
from absolutely everything so I
shouldn't lose all the things that I
have here but of course we need to add
this functionality to the save button as
well so let's do
that inside the save function here
instead of saving the graph we're going
to
save the
world and loading the world when the
application starts it's going to be
pretty similar to what we have done here
by loading the graph but we replace
these so World string is what comes from
world and then World
info we take here World
string like so and now I'm going to keep
this for reference but the way we Define
the world and the graph is going to be a
little opposite way so so first the
world is going to come from World info
if it exists then world is going to load
from World info in the same way we were
loading the graph earlier and otherwise
Define a new world with an empty graph
like
this so now this graph is going to come
from the world instead
and we don't need this code anymore now
World load this is what we're going to
do today focus on how to load the
information stored there as a Json
string so let's go and open world JS and
just below the Constructor I'm going to
implement here a
static method called load with the info
and then just return a new world
where we load the graph from the info
graph like this this is the quickest
thing that we could do and get something
that actually works now if I go back
here and
refresh you're going to see the shape is
still here but the markings are not
there and also every time we refresh the
trees are a little bit different so
that's something that I don't really
like maybe we want to keep the tree
locations so that everything is exactly
as we as we know it and the markings of
course are gone and one more issue with
this implementation is that now we do
call the world
Constructor which calls generate and
this does a lot of work really a lot of
work for big Maps this can take even
minutes and you'll see that later when
we we work with real world data but
basically when we load this it shouldn't
need to generate anything we should just
be able to restore all the generated
items from this information and that's
what we are going to do next so let's
begin here
by defining an empty world first one
that does call generate since the graph
is empty there's nothing there really
and then start populating the items so
the graph this first item right here
this one is going to come from loading
the graph from the information like that
and here we just return this world that
only contains the graph at the
moment save and refresh and now we get
this and this is okay the world just
shows the graph because the other things
are empty so envelopes Road borders
buildings these are not there not yet at
least and we're going to need to
populate them also these properties
should come from our local storage but
one thing that you should note is that
when I drag this things start appearing
again because the generate starts to
function again the at from here inside
of animate when the graph changes the
world does regenerate based on the graph
so just for you to know that this is
expected
Behavior so let's begin by taking all of
these attributes now
from the info here so this world is also
going to get the road width roundness
building width minimum length spacing
and the tree size from
the
info in case we want to generate roads
with different properties here then they
will come from the local storage and now
we proceed to generate these
envelopes and the way we do that is the
same way we did for the graph this load
method we have to implement load methods
for the envelope
as well and make them proper objects not
just raw information from this info here
so I'm going to say that the world
envelopes are going to be coming from
the info envelopes which are just info
not actual envelopes where we map them
so that each element e is going to
be envelope load that information
now we go to the envelope primitive here
and we have to implement a load for it
because this generate polygon is also
quite an expensive function and I don't
want to just call envelope with that
information the skeleton for example and
regenerate it I'm going to implement
here a way to create an empty envelope
one that if we don't pass a skeleton
then none of these
happen and our static function for
loading is just going to get the
information and
generate an empty envelope it will have
the type of object envelope and it will
have for example the draw and this other
method in it but then the skeleton of
this envelope is just going to come from
from the info by generating a new
skeleton from
the P1 and P2 of info skeleton like this
now technically these should be also
cast as points but I think it's going to
be okay and then the
poly we have to add a polygon load
method from this info
poly and now we can return this envelope
like so and the polygon load method here
at the
top a static load given the
info I'm going to return a new
polygon from these info points but I am
mapping them now to actual point objects
this is important otherwise some errors
will
come now save re
refresh and I have some errors here
because
I accidentally forgot to
remove
this I wanted to replace this with World
previously and I made the mistake save
and refresh and now the envelopes are
showing as well now the next thing here
in line is the road
borders this is is not so demanding
because they are just segments so Road
borders
is Road
borders map each border to a new
segment P1 and P2 and again I don't
bother casting these as points we don't
call any methods of those points in our
code so I just save some time by not
knowing it but the proper implementation
would have that cast also here and maybe
segment end point should have also this
load functionality there that would be
the most proper but um I'm starting to
want to end this so I can focus on phase
three now here the buildings are
next let's write here World
buildings info
buildings
map new building by loading it we have
to do this here but it's straightforward
so in our building item here just give
it a static method that loads this
info and we return a new building This
Time by loading the
polygon of the info
base and here we have to specify the
height as well so that the building
remembers its height from the original
info we didn't really play with
different Heights or anything like that
but this makes the code more proper
let's save and refresh and now the
buildings are there as well without the
need to generate
them next we
have the
trees let's do something
also here I'm just going to go through
each
tree and generate the new tree here I
don't think it needs any load because
the processing that happens for trees is
actually in the in the draw so if I open
here tree
ejs this generate level is called here
while drawing and all we need to do here
really is initialize this generating the
first is just creating a single poly
basically so not much trouble to just
reinitialize the trees trees can be
quite problematic in the generation
process because here generate takes a
lot of effort for the trees if you
remember we had this while loop here
that tries to add a lot a lot of trees
and it's going to try again and again
and again and then reset and again and
again but now we are going
to tell
here which locations to use so that part
is gone and if we refresh now we'll
actually see that every time we refresh
the trees are going to be at the same
locations always because now there's no
more Randomness at play when loading
this world from local storage now for
the markings to work we also need those
Lane guides they are next in line here
actually so let's take the lane guides
as
well Lane
guides we map
them two new
segments with the same points and now
the only thing left are these markings
here and um this will be a
problem because if I'm going to inspect
them here World info markings the ones
that I
saved we can see that there's no
information here telling what type of
marking this is the type of object
doesn't serialize in JavaScript oh yeah
I can tell that this is a traffic light
and it was saved with the state of red
but um
yeah it's just guesswork for many of
these or this image I can tell that it's
the start because it's the only one that
has an image this has two borders so
might be a parking or I don't know
Crossing could be as well so we actually
need to store the type of these markings
with the object as well as an attribute
and that means we have to open up these
markings
again and edit all of them and tell this
one that this type is a
Crossing save and this
type is a
light and
save and this one it's a marking that
hasn't
been inherited from and shouldn't really
be used like this but I will give it a
type also for
consistency and then this
is uh par
King and this
is
start and this
is a stop
this
is
Target and this
yield and now if we go back here we need
to generate the world and save it with
markings that have this type so the
original ones
are lost forever pretty much let's
refresh and add new markings I hope I
remember where I put them
before these were the traffic lights and
um I think I had the parking here maybe
I had the crossing somewhere here I
don't really know car was starting here
I
think let's put um let's put the stop
let's put it here because this kind of
looks like a priority line I think I'm
happy with this so let's save again and
refresh and the markings are not there
but now if we do look in the information
that they
have the type is there so I do know this
thing with two borders now it's a
Crossing so we do have what we need to
load them into memory as proper objects
I'm going to close all of these open
files
now and in World JS let's write
this world
markings we remap the information from
the markings to marking
load M like so and we have to implement
this load method next so inside of
marking
JS
here static load the info and here we
have to do a switch based on that type
that we now have so switch info type and
just going to take these in order from
here case
Crossing return new
Crossing
at
the info center X info center y we have
to create a new point and this is the
direction Vector
X Direction
Vector
Y and uh the width and the height are
like that and I have to copy this for
all of them pretty much
much and it would be quite a lot
of code here and many many lines so I'm
going to extract these two longer ones
at the top it's going to
be the same for all of them all of them
have this center
location and
this direction Vector there for sure
short I'm just going
to put this one
here and
now here we can type
point
there and
with and
height and close this in one line which
is much nicer I think and we can copy
this
seven times this is going to be now
light
marking
parking
start
stop
Target Target and
yield
yield let's save and
refresh and there they are our markings
are now here great so this now works but
what if we want to store many scenarios
many worlds we want to play with this
and create a bunch of different worlds
I'm going to teach you how to stored
them as a file and then load them from
the file that you stored them
in this is also going to help with
memory problems if the world is too big
and it doesn't fit in local
storage so here inside of this save I'm
going to go at the top and uh Define an
a
tag
which we will artificially click to
download a world
file now the Syntax for this I won't
explain in too much detail but basically
we will use Json here so I am going to
specify that we use application Json and
um just in case
utf8 and we encode this
information like that coming from the
string of the current world
object now here we generate the file
name and it's going to be name. World by
default but depending on your browser
settings you're may be asked to enter
the name when you save the
file and then here I'm going to set the
attribute to download and pass this file
name as well and now we can trigger
click which is going to start the
download so when we press the save
button all this will happen and it will
put the world information in a file
called
name.or but you can change this name
just the extension world is important
let's now save and refresh and let's
save this world
file you probably don't see these uh
screens here where I'm entering the name
but it did save somewhere on my computer
so this I have a backup of it and now
let's remove it and try to have a new
world maybe different looking let's just
use this kind
of square shape and maybe give it a
diagonal like so and let's save this one
as well and I'm going to use a new name
for that and now when we refresh here I
am going to get the new one the first
one is lost basically but we can get it
back if we Implement load functionality
from a
file and I'm going to do that here below
the save
function we are going to have another
function called
load and this is going to be linked to
U file input you'll see we get the first
first file from
there and if there is no file let's just
give here a quick alert that you haven't
selected
anything and return we don't want to get
to this part of the code here so we
begin to read the information from the
file and we read it s
text then unload I'm going to pass this
callback function here given an event as
the parameter I will take the
content of
this file like this and parse it because
it's a string by
default and now we can use this
information to load a new world so world
is going to be load this new
data and what I'm going to do now to
prevent reinitializing a bunch of
objects is I'm going to set this
information in local storage
here and then reload the page so
basically this button is going to reload
the page after it stored the world in
the new local storage item here but uh
one thing we still need to do is this
world needs to be reassigned to
something else and it's a const so going
back up here I'm going to change this
world into a let and this should work to
call this function we're going to need
um file input and I'm going to put it
here and give it also a label
for this file
input and the class I'm going to make it
look like the other buttons in CSS
otherwise it's very ugly I think and um
I will use
this emoji of a folder here and the
input
itself let's put it like this the type
will be file and ID is this file input
it will accept files of type world and
unchange we call our load with the event
information which file did we select now
if we save and refresh we're going to
see here some quite bad layout
happening but let's see if it works so
pressing this it asks me to select the
file and I'm going to select the first
one that I had
previously and I got it
back great only thing now to style this
to make it look like the other buttons
and I do that in Styles CSS I'm just
going to reuse this
style like
so and the default styles for these are
a little bit different I'm going to for
for both of them to have this inline
block
display and um I want to hide the
contents of the file type
input as well so we just see that emoji
there save refresh and now it looks like
that and when we refresh the page we
still have this world but now I can
change to the other one we created and
it's here every time we refresh it's
still this one until we change to
another one I'm now constantly selecting
different files there but you don't see
those windows my recorder doesn't catch
them one thing I would like when storing
these worlds is also to keep
the viewport information part of the
world itself like how should it be
presented because here it doesn't show
everything and I always seem to scroll
zoom out like this so maybe this world
should look like this by default we can
do that by storing the viewport zoom and
offset information part of the world
itself let's go back to index HTML in
our save function and here at the top
I'm going to do just that
world Zoom his viewport
Zoom World offset is
viewport
offset and now let's save this refresh
and put again this reference Here and
Now save again I'm going to overwrite
the previous
worlds that's one and the other
one
like this so now they should have that
information in them but if we refresh
the viewport isn't adapting to it so we
have to do that and also make sure that
the world is going to load that
information from the info so inside of
world JS here I'm going to also type
World Zoom comes from the info zoom and
World offset comes from info
offset and back in index HTML where we
Define our viewport here let's pass it
also to zoom and the offset of the world
and handle it inside of viewport JS in
the Constructor these will have some
default values in case they don't
exist but otherwise here let's just
pass that and the offset this is fine if
the offset is not specified so I'm just
going to say if there is an offset set
it to that offset otherwise whatever we
had previously save refresh and now we
get this exactly as we wanted and the
other
one works as
well thanks for watching if you want to
learn how to integrate the self-driving
car with this new world watch this video
on my channel you may also want to watch
these other two videos that teach how to
use real world data from open street map
and how to create the mini map I hope
you liked this course and if you did
please remember to like subscribe to me
and to free code camp and share the
course with others so they can learn as
well see you guys and stay tuned for
phase three it will start soon I promise